so uh Buddha judge finally makes his way
down to East Palestine runs away from
some journalists who asked a rather
simple question why did it take three
weeks for you to get down here why did
you only come after Donald Trump did and
will you apologize I think those are
really good questions considering many
of the residents of this town have been
asking where is the Biden Administration
but of course Buddha judge runs off and
then the press secretary for Buddha
judge says I'm not going to answer any
questions on camera wow the big story
right now that's getting some traction
online is Joy Behar on The View said
they this is what they voted for they
voted for Trump he did this it's Trump's
fault now some people have taken that
and they're saying that this is the view
saying they deserved it
and it's like well kind of it's a little
strong she's basically blaming them for
voting for the guy saying well you voted
for him this is what you get that's
effectively what they're saying so we'll
break that story down and talk about
that and then we'll talk about the
reporters and then I want to talk about
this uh you guys heard about this Emily
korres woman
the uh jury 4 person I guess in the
grand jury case against Trump and
whatever and she's completely unhinged
and there's rumors circulating now that
she tried wearing a cape to work which
is unconfirmed I don't know if that's
true but she definitely comes off as
unhinged anti-trumper this may have
completely undermined their case against
Trump because now there's a public
spectacle of an anti-trump person acting
very crazy and that uh well it's not
confidence building in any potential
indictment so we'll talk about that
before we get started my friends head
over to timcast.com click that join us
button to become a member and support
our work as a member you'll get access
to a massive library of members only
content we have a new format it is live
now so once we wrap this show the live
portion around 10 o'clock we then
immediately set up a Live members only
version you can now watch us record the
members only live after that around 11
o'clock it just becomes a video that you
can watch at any time whenever you want
on the website and then we'll be
integrating a Discord server for chat
and Collins hopefully by next week which
means if you remember you can actually
call and say you know hey here's some
thoughts that I had so we can pre-screen
some of this stuff beforehand and if
you're in the Discord we can tell you
who the guest is going to be in advance
so you can think of any questions you
might want to have I'm really excited
for this with your support at
timcast.com we're able to keep the show
going we're launching a new show
tomorrow at 1pm at youtube.com Tim cats
a new show the culture war with Tim pool
our first guest is going to be Ali
London also there is a Mr bocus Cat
who's trying to headbutt me but it's
okay we love him joining us today we got
a couple people joining us today we got
Clint Russell and Josie the redheaded
libertarian right uh Clint Russell host
of liberty lockdown as well as co-host
of the debauchers tower gang I am
Twitter husband to miss queen of Liberty
Twitter Josie over here just kidding
um and I uh I literally lost my channel
on YouTube the day after I was on with
you guys two months ago and I got it
back two hours before I'm on today so
instead of getting people to come and
subscribe to liberty lockdown I'm just
going to tell everybody go to timcast
and sign up to become a supporting
member because you guys are doing more
to to bring back Free Speech than
anybody else in my opinion so Josie
hi I'm Josie I do outside media work
here at timcast.com and I am the
redheaded libertarian over at Twitter
I'm Ian cross on what's Happening pork
chopula said tonight herdian's finally
going to do the backflip it's not true
Mr Bock is yelling
Mr Focus maybe he wants to go out I
don't know I'm gonna keep my eyes on
Buckle we brought him up early today try
and keep him up for the entire show care
everywhere yep but that's okay you know
no outfit is complete without cat hair
it has been joyous having him here so
I'm so happy I'm a little bed and
everything and he won't he won't send it
because he's a cat he will you need to
get a box
you need to just get like a small box
and put it there he'll jump in it and
just you know okay
really good idea all right we got surge
pressing the buttons yo what's up guys
um yeah ready to go on you guys all
right let's jump into this first store
we got this from The Daily Mail really
Moment The View audience gasps when
liberal host Joy Behar tells East Ohio
town where toxic Train derailed that it
had it coming after voting for Trump
she kinda said that you know whenever I
hear stuff like this I'm like oh let me
listen to this what did she really say
and what she really said was they voted
for Trump he had this guy on his team
who was deregulating the stuff that's
what you voted for and then another one
says it's Trump's fault as if to imply
not that they deserved it but that it's
what they voted for I said the same
thing about Biden supporters but I do
not believe that what happened in East
Palestine is the fault of deregulation
or Donald Trump it's the fault of well
there's a lot of reasons that there's a
lot of problems with this one the rail
workers have been complaining about the
private companies and and the safety
issues whether or not they deregulate
some of these things is not an excuse
for a company to do things poorly not to
mention you were talking about this
before the show the infrastructure bill
so when they were coming out and saying
that what were they saying that like
social justice was infrastructure
everything was infrastructure Child Care
was infrastructure that was a big one
anything that they wanted Federal
funding for became infrastructure I
believe they said abortion was
infrastructure
um uh yeah the child care is a big one
so they were really going at any sort of
women's rights that was all women's
rights were infrastructure everything
was infrastructure except infrastructure
the railroads however they did
appropriate money for the infrastructure
bill
um in for the rails from the
infrastructure bill and I think it was
102 billion dollars went to the rails
let me let's let's play this clip maybe
it won't be it might be too mind-numbing
but we'll try playing it anyway
you want to set the audio because it
seems to me that the Republicans are
obsessed with this notion of the free
market and they don't like a lot of
regulations because it means profit get
profit but they I know these okay I'm
sorry the Family Guy joke where they're
watching The View and all the winners
it's true no the regulation is about
companies existing at all so let me just
say as we're getting through this clip
Donald Trump wanted to deregulate wanted
to put uh remove a lot of these what's
what's your book is doing he want to get
rid of these environmental regulations
because companies couldn't operate here
at all and he needs to make them
competitive with China so what happens
is in the U.S the Democrats enact a
bunch of regulations making it too
expensive for a lot of Corporations to
exist they then move overseas where
Democrats then cut the taxes on
importing these Goods making it the only
thing they can do and and the box is
working Mr bocus went right for the
bucks he sleeps in that box anyway let's
play this clip more regulations there
were very few plane crashes thank God
and that's because the industry is
highly regulated we have to pay for
regulation and safety standards the
bigger wise where are we we're all going
to go up in Flames Norfolk Southern
gives as much Democrats as Republicans
as a very powerful Lobby that is trying
to block regulation and this train to
Sarah's point two miles long with two
full-time employees and a trainee on it
because the last Administration rolled
it down to only one having worker they
happen to have it too one thing I just
want to say is I do think this was an
unforced error by President Biden it was
20 days before we had secretary Buda
judge go down 10 days before he put out
a statement acknowledging it yeah this
is Trump's country he won by 40 points
he is a president for all Americans I
believe that but he needs to show that
he is but it was time for him
who is a president for all Americans
he's saying is she saying Biden is yeah
this is like the canned fake it's just
it's uttered by the way he plays someone
with deep ties to the chemical industry
in charge of the epa's chemical safety
office that's who you voted for in that
District Donald Trump who reduces all
safety
those voters saw something on the ground
that probably resonates
and say who's doing the job here forget
about the photo option
I think this is Donald Trump's fault
I think this is Donald Trump's fault so
wait I think as we are watching but Mr
bocus peed
he ran into a corner and peed a little
bit or a little jerk I was trying to
listen to Joy Behar and I'm looking at
Mr Boca this is starfish I was like this
is awkward so Jack vesobic tweeted Joy
Behar says East Palestine got what they
deserved because they voted for Trump
that's who you voted for and then Brian
krasenstein says nowhere in the clip did
she say that's what they deserved so but
like Jack didn't quote her he's implying
that's what she was saying and he's not
wrong it's a little strong I would say
yeah but she's basically saying you vote
for it that's what happens I say this
all the time I say you vote for Biden
you get what you deserve sure you
deserve what you ask for but I don't
believe what happened in East Palestine
is a problem with Donald Trump because
Joe Biden has been president now for two
years and so what like that the two
years Joe Biden was trapped in that that
Cube or whatever that that sheep that
the the Zod got trapped in in Superman 2
or whatever like he's Frozen in Time
like uh spinning through space unable to
enact any of these policies unable to
fix anything and then after the train to
Roman happens he's he's is frozen in ice
and and booty judge was uh fell into a
crevice somewhere and they were just
they were trying to get there but they
really couldn't it's still Trump's fault
Biden's been president for two years how
is it Trump's fault what is wrong with
these people they're insane here's the
problem too it's like because the
Democrats always believe in regulation
they make it so that our industry our
domestic industry particular
infrastructure industry including
Airlines as well as uh Railways are not
competitive globally so then they turn
around and they say okay well we have to
have harsh regulations to protect for
liability for disasters the truth of the
matter is if you if you allowed them to
just compete on an even playing field
they wouldn't need all these liability
protections but because they now have
them they they behave in ways that are
are extraordinarily Reckless and then
they're offered liability Shields by the
very government that is allegedly
regulating them at the end of the day
the only people that get hurt are the
people in these towns and it's just
tragic
mind-numbingly annoying yes that no
matter what happens it's Donald Trump's
fault it's like my my guy it is two
three it is two two three two zero two
three that's the date it is February 23
2023 25 months it has been 25 months
since Donald Trump was in office not to
mention there's a lame duck session and
they're like well clearly the train
wreck that happened you know a couple
weeks ago Trump's fault Trump's fault
that it happened because uh you know all
the things Trump did Biden just didn't
know right you know until now and I
believe it was a billion dollars that
they passed for infrastructure in
December of 21. that was you know
Biden's bill that's what he wanted he
got it and then you have all these
disasters and they still manage to Pivot
to blame Trump it's just it's just on
its face I like how the audience gasped
when they heard yeah I mean that's most
of the audience leans towards Joy
behar's politics I would assume and that
was even kind of startling for them well
the issue is it's what I've been talking
about for a while that when you build an
audience they expect you to give them
what they want to hear and so the view
has cultivated Trump derangement
syndrome it's gonna be it's it's gonna
like Trump's going to be dead it's gonna
be like 50 years in the future and the
president is going to be you know part
of the cyborg
Democrat Party or something and his name
is going to be like zyborg and they're
going to be like well clearly this is
Trump's fault
cyborg Obama they'll be blaming the Deep
fix of
Trump's fault I mean if you want to get
scary and talk about like 1984 ask and
and creating a villain for everyone to
Rally around I wouldn't be surprised if
they did start deep faking some kind of
Perpetual villain imagine what they
could do now imagine what they could do
then with videos of terrorists or
whatever they could make a video of
someone and say oh we found this in a
cave somewhere here's what here's I'm
saying and people just believe it yeah
we'll probably hit a point where they
create the first digital villain like a
real not even a real ever was a real
person it'll be a completely fictitious
character and everyone they'll just get
enough people to believe it and right
now they have Trump and he's real and
they just ride it out and and he's still
in the spotlight and so anything he does
is still can be villainized why do you
think this is my best my best guess is
that they're so confused and terrified
about the future of the economics in the
country that they're just just blaming
they need a villain they need a villain
so that they can have a hero or they can
be the hero and their villain and they
tried to do DeSantis and they tried to
do Tucker Carlson and none of it worked
I tried Rogan Joe Rogan yeah kind of I
don't I don't think really like they
really tried Tucker and and DeSantis
during the coveted period it seemed like
they really went after Rogan for a
couple months and then everyone's like
we've listened to this guy talk for
thousands of hours you're not going to
convince us otherwise but I agree I mean
Trump I think is clearly the he's the
he's the galvanizing whipping post of
our society like that's that's what they
use to beat every time they screw up
terribly and they can still say well you
guys screwed up and you voted for this
clown for four years and now
everything's a disaster because of him
the reality is it's almost none of it's
Trump's fault none of the things he
wanted to do got done because he had the
Deep State working against him the
entire time he couldn't do anything like
it he didn't do anything everybody was
working against him Trump should be we
should give it a new definition a a
trump as a scapegoat that is actually
the solution of the problem at the cause
of right so then you can say like well
that's clearly a trump you know they're
they're blaming someone for the problem
who's actually been fixing it and then
there's got to be inverse of Biden a
Biden is the person who causes the
problem and they defend and claim he's
solving it yeah Putin's a trump and uh
how she's abiding
whenever I get people with to tell me
that they can't stand Donald Trump I'll
tell them well particularly one things I
love about what he did his president was
getting us out of trans-pacific
partnership he signed it away really
quick there's this thing called the
investor State dispute settlement clause
in that uh trans-pacific partnership the
deal where they're going to allow
Malaysian oil companies and other
corporations to sue the American
government for discrimination if we
chose not to buy their oil or something
they could sue our country and then we
as taxpayers would have to pay these
fines to these corporations and they
were trying to put that through Obama
was trying to pass that and basically
make Us corporate service serves
um and then Trump immediately for
whatever reason ended it and when I tell
people that and and much more succinctly
they they almost always are like
jaw-droppingly
the left to find that out the left was
opposing the TPP but this is a during
the weird shift period where the left
used to be Pro Assange anti-war anti-tpp
and then Trump came around and all of a
sudden it started to shift and invert
now the left is pro-war anti-assage
anti-free speech they're basically
neocons but you know and antibody bodily
autonomy I mean it's quite the shift
it's horrifying man this is why I as
much as I detest Trump for totally
opposite reason I had to test him
because he surrounded himself with the
swamp when he was allegedly draining it
he didn't do any of that he didn't fire
fauci he uh was it worse than say Obama
no was it worse than Clinton probably
not was it worse than Bush no but he was
worse than Reagan but he ran on being
I'll take it he ran on be my guy though
sure I mean I I was thinking about this
earlier and I'm like Donald Trump John
Bolton uh you know the the the worst
possible guy to bring in uh what what
else you know he he smack talks I don't
know what did Donald Trump do that has
people so mad at him
and the reality is he pissed off the
establishment by fighting against them
though that explains why the cult is
against him but then I hear people like
you know Luke for instance who's like
you know he did this or Dave Smith you
know Trump is bad he did you know drone
strikes he expanded this he blah blah
blah bump stocks bump stock Donnie and
all that I'm like yup yup yup all that
okay now let's go back in time to Obama
gun control yup War yup more war oh way
more War uh housing crisis how about big
Banker bailouts okay let's go back to
George W bush Dick Cheney Iraq war and
Afghanistan being started
um directive 51 come on that's all
there's a whole bunch of let's go back
to Clinton now
I was much too young to know too much
about Clinton but I know enough about
Clinton and the things he did and they
want to accuse Trump of being nasty yo
Bill Clinton did it when he was in
office come on the the problem is that
Donald Trump said nasty words don't get
me started on Bill Clinton I I look at
what you know George W bush and Obama
are the presidents in my adult life and
the bad things they did and Trump is
infinitely better than they were so
people come out and they say oh Trump
did this thing bad this thing bad this
thing bad this thing bad and I'm like oh
wow those are like substantially less
bad than Obama and George W bush Clinton
and Reagan Reagan he brought in no fault
divorce and gun control come on I don't
know why everybody celebrates Reagan but
I don't look I was a baby when Reagan
was around then we got George H.W bush
we got what Desert Storm with that guy
it just seems like it's all trash you're
right and then you get Donald Trump like
that's pretty good well it's
if it weren't for 2020 I could probably
agree with you but when he passes
trillions of dollars in those stimulus
bills and he permits fauci this little
Gremlin Tyrant to lock us down it's like
no you can no longer you can no longer
be looked at in any positive light you
allowed the entire world because they
followed in America's footsteps to
essentially derail the global economy
that is a catastrophic mistake but but I
I look at it not like you can't just say
president good bad it's it's like what
did they do that was good what did they
do that was bad can you can you guys
think of anything Obama did that was
good
if I if you give me an hour maybe I
can't he's the president of the TPP the
trans-pacific partnership right so it's
more International Trade these are laws
that get enacted on the American people
without proper legislation because oh we
have to abide by the treaty that means
this country has to do these things like
we're forced to go to war because of
NATO the American people the the
Congress can only declare war but
because of NATO so that's what they
tried doing Obama had the ndaa
indefinite detention provision they
could rendition you into a black site
off uh outside of the country
indefinitely they signed that this dude
had a whole bunch big Banker bailouts
Occupy Wall Street was protesting him so
I look at Donald Trump and I'm like fine
how about we say this
Trump's a negative 12. Obama was a
negative 56. George W Bush was negative
84. Clinton was a negative 80. it's like
so Trump is he's bad but he's like the
least bad and closer we got to good I
totally agree but then I look at foreign
policy and I'm like he's actually the
best yes
hands down and didn't didn't Ron Paul
would have been better yes of course
didn't Trump get us out of uh the Paris
Accord and the Iran deal like didn't
didn't get us out of both those that's
great Biden brought us right back oh
yeah he brought us right back yeah I'm
not getting out of the Iran deal was
good why was that good
am I the only one
the Iran nuclear deal the Iran nuclear
deal was to they had basically agreed to
have their their nuclear facilities
inspected and I thought that was a great
thing why why do we want to have a
catalyst for war with them I think the
inspection and treaty is potentially a
catalyst for war with them
well I think I think that if you're
inspecting it then you know that they're
not creating nuclear weapons there's no
you know uh imperative to strike so who
who uh who uh enacted who is the
president which Administration brought
about the Iran nuclear deal I thought it
was Obama was it Obama I thought so and
which Administration produced stuxnet to
blow up Iranian centrifuges probably I
think it was Obama too so look I got to
be honest I probably don't know enough
about the specifics in the deal other
than I'm typically anti-interventionist
and if they don't give me a good reason
why they're engaging in these kinds of
policies sure so I can only say this you
know fair point I don't know enough
about it but I'm certainly not going to
trust Obama who enacts a treaty and then
blows them up I agree man and you
shouldn't trust them and that's why you
can't give them any of these guys a ton
of credit for anything that they do but
I'll Grant you yes Trump is probably the
best president of my lifetime we still
had 2020 which was maybe the worst year
of my lifetime yeah but it's the
governors who did it you know you can
blame Trump for a lot I mean she got rid
of Burke she got rid of fauci he
shouldn't have promoted lockdowns in the
first place that gave the launching
Point yes to these Governors and he
probably could have used some emergency
powers to stop some of it
but it was ultimately the governors and
Donald Trump took a constitutional
approach where he was like look 10th
Amendment I can't the governor is going
to do it the states have the right to do
their thing and and legislate the way
they want the reason the Libertarians
are so hard on Trump for that period is
because of our understanding of Austrian
economics and the the trillions that he
allowed to be created in the thin air
that we're now suffering the
inflationary process to this day and yes
it's not entirely his fault and yes he
wasn't responsible for all of it but if
he's going to go up there and say that
I'm I'm here to drain the swap I am
going to point to you and let you know
that the media is full of crap and I'm
going to be the one guy that tells you
the truth and then you allow the biggest
Liars on earth like Anthony fauci to go
up there and just lie to us for a year
straight and you don't fire him when you
have a chance sorry there's just a
disconnect there that I can't remember
yeah it's bad sure but I'm just saying
like I'm just relatively I'm just kind
of over it because because everything
else is terrible because everything else
was a hundred-fold worse and I created a
bunch of really good things yeah and I
look at what's going now in East
Palestine and I'm just like now I just
like the guy like I saw the video of him
at McDonald's talking about him knowing
the menu better and I'm like I just I
just like this guy so much better than
these other pieces of trash let me pull
up the story we got some timcast.com
I'm not here for politics put a judge
press secretary Dodges reporters
questions in East Palestine Ohio the
people here have been quite tight-knit
about when we can ask questions I also
want to shout out this really cool image
that I'm pretty sure was like AI
generated of a reporter chasing Buddha
judge who for some reason is on vacation
but I I like the picture anyway Turning
Point reporter Kalin D Almeida
confronted Buddha judge during his
Thursday visit to Ohio the Ohio
community regarding his response to to
the disaster earlier this month the
American people doesn't seem to be very
confident in your ability to do your job
will you be resigning anytime soon I'm
not here for politics he said I'm here
to make sure the community can get what
they need now I'll say this Savannah
Hernandez also confronted Buddha judge
her question was hitting the nail on the
head with the hammer she said why did it
take three weeks for you to get here
why did you only come after Trump
already came and will you apologize to
people who live here those are three
questions that everyone's been asking
everyone's been talking about and even
the people who live there have been
saying where's the bite Administration
where's Booty judge this is something he
can literally answer why weren't you
here just simple question I think that
was fantastic a fantastic question the
are you going to quit question it's kind
of like okay like you know he can't
answer that and that's the one he
actually sticks around for with Savannah
he just runs away take a look at this
Mary Kate why did it take you an entire
two and a half weeks to actually get
here to respond to East Palestine will
you apologize to the residents of this
city and he's worthless and then here's
the best way press secretary of the
secretary of the Department of
Transportation don't you think you
should be able to ask questions from the
American public that absolutely I would
like to do it without the camera on oh
what a smarty piece of garbage turn the
camera off so I can say nasty things to
you so I see I we over and over and over
again this is what we're getting from
the bite Administration dude just own it
have some humility and try and win back
some support Buddha judge should have
should have uh like he can just say you
know we probably should have got here
sooner we tried as hard as we could I I
think I I'll have to apologize for not
being here as soon as I can I know but
trust me I'm here for you now just say
something like that instead it's I was
here he says we have been here as an
Administration since a few hours after
the accident oh okay yeah in in because
it's a disaster for them politically and
only because Trump shows up do they
respond in any way so then I see a video
of Donald Trump ordering Burgers I get a
warm fuzzy feeling and I'm like man
there are people right now who hate
Trump who want DeSantis who are tweeting
that Trump is just doing this for a
photo op he's politicizing it all the
big Trump supporters are gloating and
accusing DeSantis blah blah blah and I'm
just like
I don't care dude the Trump people over
here the 10s people over here I'm just
gonna I'm gonna tell all of you as a
consistent independent moderate
individual all I care about is that the
net outcome of Donald Trump's action was
positive for the people who live there
and the net outcome for what Biden has
been doing has been neglect and maybe a
slight net positive I'm not going to
just come out and be like booty judge
evil I mean he's there so something is
getting done fine but it's only in
response to what Trump was already
starting have having done or it seems
like it only was I don't know Trump's
the only presidential candidate to
actually go there the fact that Nikki
Haley Vivek Rama Swami not to be fair
literally just announced the other day
so I don't know if he has a plan but uh
Nikki Haley she's been running I mean is
she's not going to come down and visit
they she Benny Johnson gave 20 grand to
these people I keep mentioning him
because it's like he's just some guy in
the internet and he did more than
anybody else save Trump now not now
they're showing up look you can rag on
Trump all you want sorry
I hope I really do hope Trump's sitting
behind the scenes going like if I show
up and help all of these suffering
people then they'll believe in me
I'm like oh no we're being tricked into
voting for the guy who thinks he has to
help the American people to actually get
elected
yeah okay I'll take it I think the fact
that Pete butter j said um
I'm not here for politics yeah right I
think that he was absolutely there for
politics but I think that that was
almost a slight to Donald Trump to say
oh because that's that's their narrative
is that Trump's there for politics but
he's like I'm not there for politics
like I'm not going to be political about
this like you are literally here for
like this is your job your job is being
here for politics like you're not here
out of the goodness of your heart right
now
you're here for politics you're here
because you have to be because Donald
Trump called you out I'm stupid and that
may be true of Donald Trump of course
but like here's a guy who's like hey I
know how to get elected I'll help people
and then Buddha judge goes uh fine okay
I guess I'll go this is the most
beautiful thing about the Biden
Administration yeah Kareem Jean-Pierre
you got Buddha you got Biden who's
barely functioning all of them have this
deep-seated disdain for the American
people that there's just this thin
veneer that washes away when there's any
sort of controversy you see Korean
Jean-Pierre she kicks out that African
reporter because he's asking like one
semi-hard question
um
who can't even you know bring himself to
pretend to care about the people of East
Palestine it did like he's hilarious
he's been absent over like every major
transportation disaster yes and it's all
falling apart under his watch his job I
I just I want to lay out the reality for
people Buddha judge is a small town
mayor he runs for president for some
reason because they got nobody and then
because Langley told him to and they
said they wanted all the moderates to
drop out and then endorse Joe Biden so
that Joe Biden would get boosted in the
primary and they probably said okay
we'll give you a cushy do nothing job
like Transportation secretary and he's
like sure we're gonna do nothing just
we'll put your name on exactly dude and
so now it's like now he's showing up I
bet he's on the phone like why am I
doing this I'm gonna quit like you can't
quit you can't you agree to this well
the irony of the whole thing and you can
find this clip when Pete butter j
accepted the position as Transportation
secretary
the whole interview they're like well
why did you take this he goes well
brace yourself I've always loved trains
that's right I've always loved trains he
looks like a guy that likes trains yeah
and that was that was it yeah I like to
ride on them I like to watch them this
whole thing was about how much you love
trains and then this happens with a
train that I just I love it because he
looks like a guy that just wanted
paternity leave for like the rest of his
life and he didn't get it and they're
like oh there's actually catastrophes
that happen if I'm utterly terrible at
this position and he is he's horrible he
is he's putting to the test like how bad
you can be at your job before someone
fires you fauci has been trying for 40
years desperately for anyone within the
American political establishment to
finally conclude oh my God you're
responsible for so Much Death and
destruction we gotta get rid of you nope
comes in and he's like look in a year I
can have the airlines in complete
disarray I can have it to the point
where you're not sure if you're going to
get to your destination on any flight
we've had two close calls on airlines in
like a month where there was one FedEx
cargo plane coming in and almost hit I
think it was a Southwest flight that was
another close encounter Buddha judge I
would say he's not even asleep on the
job so here's here let's pull up this
article there's the supply chain issues
we have we we're using uh AI to generate
some of these images and I'm assuming
they typed in the headline or they typed
in reporter asks Buddha judge question
about train derailment and so you can
see in the background there's a train a
reporter but Buddha judge is wearing a
Hawaiian shirt and holding some kind of
fruity beverage and I'm assuming it's
because when the AI was scouring the
internet for information about Buddha
judge it was like okay his the Buddha
judge is the guy on vacation who doesn't
work exactly there's probably tons of
Articles saying he's on vacation and so
the AI made that image oh my gosh didn't
he just say something I I'm totally
quoting this off the top right now but I
feel like when he was asked by a
reporter he said something like that he
on the lines of I'm not working right
now or the way that he said it though
sounded like he was on some kind of
leave
um I can't remember it if somebody finds
it and pulls I also uh would like to
point out that his lay isn't connected
around his neck it appears and it looks
like he's not using his thumb to hold
his drink he's holding it like this oh
my God he's holding his drink like that
hey I get it together I guess I guess I
guess you can
dream I guess you can hold your drink
like that but that's AI for you I just I
just love that when I saw that I asked
The Newsroom I was like what is this
like why is he wearing a Hawaiian shirt
and I'm like oh I bet the AI just as a
general search and when they search for
Buddha judge his yeah what are those
things called where you have like a
bubble of words and the most common
words are bigger than the other words oh
yeah I know what I'm talking about yeah
I know what it is no I'm not sure I
don't know a word map but I'm sure when
you when you have booty judge next time
it's like vacation not at work sleeping
vacation and that's probably why yeah
that's why the AI is like if they're
gonna make a picture of him they find
his face and then put him in a Hawaiian
shirt with a with a fruity beverage I
love I love that this guy had such high
hopes to be president of the United
States and now it's just like him and
Kamala that's the best part of the bite
administration because now everybody
that's involved with him is just the
laughing stock they're such embarrassing
human beings this is how we feel but I
feel like the left might be priming him
to run for president
priming my flight to leave the country I
think it's I think it's going to be
either him or Gavin news Gavin news
newstrom
whatever yeah that's what that was
that's what I meant
um yeah so it's going to be either
either him or Gavin it depends I know
they want to put Gavin up against
DeSantis
because of their personalities and just
and Gavin's always coming after Ron
DeSantis about everything and remember
that whole the Spiel that he did about
how California is the land of the free
remember that the commercial yeah I did
a commercial like a month ago as a
transplant from California to Florida
during the covet hysteria I can't tell
you how horrific that would be to have
put the potential even of Gavin effing
Newsom as the president United States it
is the most horrifying thought to
someone like me I can't even describe it
have you seen that pure Terror in my in
my body have you seen that picture where
it's his face but it's pinned to the
back of his head and it's like a lizard
head behind it like its skin pulled over
his face he looks like a dirty car
salesman he's he gives me the
heebie-jeebies
that's like 30 year old technology let's
let's pull up this clip ladies and
gentlemen we have a new president it's
Obama or or it might be Kamala so Joe
Biden himself has repeatedly said
kamala's the president and now Kareem
Jean-Pierre says Obama's the president
you ready for this one
okay so today as you all saw just an
hour or so ago President Obama announced
that it's a part of me person invited
whoa
[Applause]
that is news okay wait one more time one
more time so today as you all saw just a
hour or so ago President Obama announced
that
pardon me personally she is so bad at
her job she read from the paper she's
looking at and said the wrong
president's name or
I'm assuming when she's reading she read
President Obama it's full on solitary
man because that guy was hasn't been
president for a long but is she reading
look she's she's reading as she she's
that that's the point so today as you
all saw just an hour or so ago President
Obama announced that yeah she's reading
off the paper she read that that her
eyes were down as she was reading that
she's reading from a paper checked out
wow I think she's checked out yeah she's
checked out I do I honestly like I
you know because like no don't no I feel
bad for him because he's just trying to
you know he's trying to chill right she
doesn't want to be transportation and
the government knocks on his door and
they're like Pete booty judge he's like
uh yeah he's like washing a pan and
they're like we need you for
transportation secretary he's like what
it's like your country needs you and
they put him on the helicopter and fly
him to DC and then he's like I'm not
doing the job and they're like well you
are and then he's just trying as hard as
he can not to do it but they won't fire
him that's true he's just like look man
it's like office can you fire me man
that's actually a really great meme can
we do that Buddha judge as the main dude
in office space yes and then you get
like I've got like seven bosses yeah so
what would you say you do here well I uh
go on vacation and paternity leave
ignore natural and man-made disasters
and
space out for about an hour if there was
like a war and then bombs were blowing
up roads would would Buddha judge be in
charge of overseeing the Reconstruction
of the roads the transportation center
is that all deferred to the military
honestly I don't think it happens yes
anything but yes he'd have some he'd
have some Authority there for sure yeah
because it's National I look at his
National Security if you like the people
of your country starve die off from
chemicals that's a loss of security in
the nation if the U.S was being bombed I
think we'd be under martial law
instantly and the military would take
over infrastructure projects that's true
we wouldn't have a civilian doing it
they might communicate with him in some
degree and have him do something they
would just like Biden might give him a
battlefield promotion and make him
Lieutenant Colonel there'd be some some
photo ops for sure like have him
standing there
[Music]
I got to be honest though I kind of feel
like if the roads were to be bombed in
like a figurative sense destroyed it
would be because of the Biden
Administration not you know not in spite
of
it's their policies that are going to
result in this so you know they blame
Donald Trump for the the the the the the
derailment but Biden has been president
for two years it's like and they passed
the infrastructure bill with 1.2 billion
dollars for the rails like and then what
did they do with it do you guys think
that Obama's secretly pulling the
strings
I think he's on a panel that that I
think there's a bunch of people that are
pulling the strings the uh the they
wrote about in Time Magazine the cabal
of Elites or whatever they called it
he's the fortification of Elections yes
he bought a house near the White House
he was caught on Mike saying the only
thing I would like better than a third
term is to not be president again and be
able to basically control this whole
operation from that from my basement I
think he's doing it that's my honest
opinion it'd be funny if he's like
literally in his basement with a like a
beard growing
and he's like just dirty and disheveled
and he's like rocking back and forth
watching the news and then he takes the
phone and he calls Biden he's like Joe
what's up with this smoke in Ohio and
Joe's like I don't know man I'm you know
I think he's got an ifb straight into
Biden's ear but bind's hard of hearing
so he's like he just keeps saying the
wrong lines even though Obama's like
look I am one of the most gifted orators
of our time and I'm talking directly
into this dude's ear and he still can't
get it right I feel for Obama ultimately
I think that Obama is is involved in
this now I haven't thought that much
because he's I haven't heard of him much
but for her to say his name like that
must that is so natural you know be kind
of cool actually if like there's a house
a block away from the White House with a
secret sub-basement you know you go in
this regular house and everything looks
normal and you go downstairs and
everything looks normal and then you
lift up like a chest and underneath it
is stairs that goes down into like this
dark Cobblestone brick castle wall and
Hillary Clinton and Obama are wearing
dark cloaks and they're like look
looking over this computer screen and
they're like oh and they're feeding
information to Joe Biden and telling
what to do I think that'd be really cool
cartoon that I'd like to write it's not
impossible I know basically I believe
anything it would be better if like
Obama is in some kind of pod with a
neural link plugged in and then like
he's got a heads-up display and he's
controlling Biden and that's why Biden's
like all messy because like when the
connectivity goes out he slurs that
explains everything it could be that the
people like Karine have no faith in
Biden like zero probably a lot of people
in that Administration have very little
to no faith in the guy and so Obama's
keeping them keeping their morale up
yeah I got your back if something
happens to him I will be here to leave
this country kind of thing well that's
that's how degraded our our political
classes that like even though everyone
there has clearly given up like it's so
crystal clear that they've all given up
on their jobs they're they're just like
we know we know that the whole country's
falling apart but
we've been told by the business class
that we're going to be taking care of
because we're just going to continue to
do our jobs and then that revolving door
into K Street we're going to get our
payday at the end of it that's I I know
that's a really jaded way of looking at
it but like tell me when you watch
Korean John Pierre speak that you don't
just sense like she is counting the days
until she gets to quit this job counting
the days it's it's almost like
um they almost dog whistle his name out
like when everyone's like okay Biden's
kind of start like all their base is
like all right Biden's starting to creep
me out and she's like yeah yeah Obama
and they're like oh oh okay yeah you got
my attention again I guess you know
maybe it's something to subconsciously
tell them that he's still involved I I
would love to be a White House Press
Secretary because it's like the one job
you don't got to take seriously you know
like like you said she's probably
counting the days yeah but she's she's
phoning it in yeah but she's still
phoning it in like if it were me I would
probably not show up half the time all
right yeah and then when I did I'd bring
like a lounge chair and I'd have like a
switch and I'd be playing Spelunky or
maybe I'd like set up a Playstation and
just be like I'm gonna play some
OverWatch get some quick no limit in and
Tim Tim and you're like we have a
question about the train derailment and
I'll be like I don't know anything about
it
like do you think the Korean John Pierre
knows what the hell's going on yeah no
she has she has a binder that's like 18
inches thick just so she apparently says
Obama's the president yeah I don't
believe she's I think she just brain
farted that's the most real I've ever
seen her I don't watch a lot of her
stuff but when she laughs and she's like
oh my gosh what yeah wow that's news
she looks like she's being watched and
she knows it just think about how
degraded of a human being you have to be
to you all day for months now she's been
lying us into World War III but the faux
pas that gets her to giggle is saying
Obama like she she can just lie through
her teeth about everything in Ukraine
honestly she probably doesn't even know
why am I why am I like she's just
reading off a paper she's Michael malice
needs to be a press secretary that'd be
funny that was the whole plan Dave Smith
malice come on let's go yeah you know
we're working on it right yeah yeah I'm
working on it I'm open to it I want to
bring like Donald Trump together man at
this point I'm like I will run as your
VP I want to sit in with the Senate and
listen all day I'd listen I listen on
this show I want to listen to like these
people get to know who they are get
malice involved get Alex Jones involved
get you involved get Tim evolved get all
these awesome politicians Dave Smith
involved like everybody I know it
doesn't have to be Donald Trump I don't
care I just want to do this for real and
at least try and steer this mechanism so
that we can turn the liberal world order
into the New World Order
effectively with like delocalized
statehood as the central back we're
gonna have to work on The Branding
because we can't call it the new world
order would you what would you what
would you put if you had Alex Jones in
your cabinet where would you put him
Secretary of War uh Alex Jones I don't
know I don't know what the cabinets
entail how that would work
um probably is like a science advisor of
some sort or at least I would I would
ask him to talk military no no
disrespect to malice but I would love to
see him as press secretary my God my God
that would be amazing yeah it'd be it
would be fun oh so fun we just like
somebody who shows up and is just like
sitting there and then points somebody
and just asking they're like what is the
pr what did the president mean when he
said you know and then insert Gaff and
it'll be like out of his mind like Joe
Biden's brain doesn't work
do you think Joe Biden knows what's
going on in Ohio and he told me to tell
you what's going on in Ohio listen up
Joe Rogan he's got he's actually just a
skin suit been flown in from Langley oh
yeah I do stuff like that that'd be fun
be like well actually Joe Biden isn't
the president it's Obama that's right
all the conspiracy theorists they were
right the whole time
there is seven look if we're gonna press
zero if we're gonna have war three I
need I need some sort of pick me up like
Alex Jones my secretary man I need it
I'm thinking like we really do need to
use modern technology to clean this oil
spill or the spill up in East Ohio like
why I keep waiting for someone to do
something miraculous in the government
like okay who's the guy that has read
about graphene technology so we can stop
creating you know planned obsolescence
of roads and rail like we can build
roads that last 170 years Railways that
don't warp you know after 40 or so
that's interesting it's it can can um a
private company get involved and do this
or do they need to be like could they
come forward and say because like we
think the military's in charge of this
right now like handling this or do we
think Pete bootage look who's in charge
we don't know we know it's the
government so can can a small business
or a business come out and say hi we
specialize including this up can we do
anything because nobody's come forward
and this happened what February 2nd yeah
February second or third okay so so it's
been three weeks yeah and the silence is
really starting to get to me I mean it's
been getting to me you can pour iron
dust into an oil spill water and the oil
coagulates around the iron then you put
a magnet in and it'll suck the oil to
the magnet you can pull it out that's
awesome let me black pill the hell out
of you guys right now if there was some
startup business that came up with the
technology to deal with this the reality
is those businesses don't exist to a
large extent because when there's a
disaster like this the government is
going to turn to an industry partner
someone who's already deeply in bed with
them and they're going to give them no
bid contracts to go and deal with this
they're not going to turn to the most
Innovative because they don't have any
political gain to be made there so until
that changes I don't know how you get
any sort of ultimate fix to what we're
talking and that's a good point it's
almost like they wait it out and they're
like all right you know the half-life of
these chemicals are I don't know I don't
know what the half-life is but they're
waiting it out and eventually it's like
okay it's going to go away on its own
and then it's going to look like we did
something to make it go away Tucker was
talking with Ben Shapiro I'm not sure
when this was but I saw a clip going
around I need to asked by Ben Shapiro
would you if you were in government stop
self-driving trucks and he goes
absolutely I'm not going to put 10
million working-class men out of out of
a job we're gonna we're gonna block this
probably with the guys with some safety
regulation but we will and that is like
it's technically correct but I don't
know if it's going to help us in the
long term technology is happening and
will continue to happen and so we have
serious problems with automation you
can't just regulate it away that's
abandoned on a bullet wound now I agree
with them like we don't want to put all
these people out of work overnight so
there probably needs to be a transition
period where you literally say the
economy will be destroyed and 10 million
people will lose their jobs overnight so
we need to find a transition so that
this kind of thing can happen and maybe
phase it in over a long period of time
or something that's a tough one because
technology is now in improving at a pace
that we've never experienced before so
the natural uh adaptation period for
Humanity for civilization for the
economy for the the workforce to adapt
to these new technologies is is faster
than we're really capable of retraining
ourselves and I think it's only going to
get harder as Ai and other things start
to get involved so it sucks because as a
Libertarian I never want to have the
government interfere and say like oh
we're going to have to have these
truckers just sit there with the AI
device for the next decade and then they
have to go get their other jobs it's
it's going to be challenging let's talk
about this story here from Newsweek
Emily cores has harmed image of trump
Georgia probe former prosecutor have you
guys seen this woman she's uh she was on
the Trump grand jury for eight months oh
my God my ex-wife she's uh uh giving
statements to various news organizations
and she is acting like a you know those
people who go on Tick Tock and they
pretend like
yes yes and they talk like this and they
Bounce Around she's going like well
wouldn't it be really crazy if Donald
Trump got indicted and you're like
what's wrong with are you having a
seizure right now she's absolutely a
furry on the weekends let's play some I
want to watch
I haven't seen I've seen pictures
this is going to blow your mind if we
can find it because this this chick is
oh my God my my sleep demon looks just
awful oh my god oh no how many people
was this all along their eyes it's not a
short list
I look at her I feel bad for her I would
say that yes okay are these recognizable
names names that people would know there
are certainly names that you would
recognize
I'm not going to speak on exact
indictments
would we be surprised are there
Bombshells of who is I don't think
indictment I don't think that there are
any giant plot twists coming I don't
think that they're any like
Giant
that's not the way I expected this to go
at all I I don't think that's
in store for anyone
it sounds terrified that if she says the
wrong thing she'll be canceled
probably not
um I wouldn't want to characterize
anyone else's reaction of course see how
she's doing that weird bouncing yes so
that's when we heard a lot in testimony
well she's toying with a felon probably
not it probably wouldn't shop by talking
about it you personally want to hear
from the formula I wanted to hear from
the former president honestly I kind of
wanted to subpoena the former president
because I got to swear everybody in
and so I thought it'd be really cool to
get 60 seconds with President Trump of
me looking at him and being like do you
solemnly swear and me getting to swear
him in I just I kind of just thought
that would be an awesome moment and
apparently she had an ice cream a a like
a Looney Tunes pop or something those
are those are really good by the way you
go to the ice cream man and it's like
shaped like Bugs Bunny or whatever's got
the gumball eyes oh but uh apparently
the D.A I'm hearing she had like an ice
cream party and they gave her ice cream
and then she was swearing in like Grand
jurors while eating some like Looney
Tunes Popsicle or something
she's got really kid like like very
young Vibes like she's 30. yeah she's
30. and did you see her do the thing
which went like this and did that weird
22 I would have believed 30 years old
that's like this is what's wrong with
our current generation oh that's
horrible now I'll say this what she just
did with all these interviews in this
media circus thing
I don't I don't I mean they'll they
gotta try and indict Trump but that
seriously just destroyed the image of
Prosecuting Donald Trump for anything
and so
people this is what the music article is
basically saying that uh there's a legal
expert saying it has uh it's giving
credence to Trump's claim that's a Witch
Hunt they're saying it's it's not gonna
end the prosecution But ultimately it
will be up to the D.A to decide whether
to move forward charges not the grand
jury the grand jury just basically
refers or recommends or doesn't
so clearly if they do indict Trump there
is now going to be a presumption uh
there's going to be there's going to be
reasonable doubt are these charges
legitimate because the whole premise of
them is this seemingly unwell woman
you know Bobby nicely putting it nicely
and uh clearly anti-trump and so the
question is
was this a real grand jury indictment
referral or are they just trying to go
after Trump and they're and they're
they're making it up does anybody don't
know how a woman like that would make it
onto a jury it feels like she would have
been flagged well I think I think in a
grand jury you don't actually have any
defense so I don't think that Trump's
people were allowed to decide who was on
the grand jury I think if that's the
case that would make a lot of sense
yeah have you guys you guys remember
this we talked about it before here pull
us up on Reddit what's up with these
tick tocks where people move like
cartoon characters super out of the loop
here to the point where I watch Tick
Tock clips on YouTube and don't have an
account I'm seeing a lot of this one
particular style that seems to be
associated with cosplay and Anime where
people move their bodies and faces in a
specifically animated way
I think Sheamus was talking about this
because uh you learned this in school
the 12 points of Animation or something
like that and my understanding was they
intentionally make them like move in a
crazy way because they're not alive and
they're missing tons of depth in their
motion and presence so if they just sat
there and talked like a regular person
you'd be missing all kinds of facial
movements and it's like it's BL it's
bland so they have them bounce and move
their mouths in weird ways and I think
what's happening is when we were younger
most of the communication we consumed
came from human beings and now what
we're consuming is coming from cartoons
and movies so people like her grow up
watching Disney and Pixar where the
characters talk like this and move
around and shake their heads and go like
that and that's what she picks up and
she begins to identify with that and
behave in that way and then most people
who still don't have that kind of twitch
are watching this going like why why are
you doing that
she's probably the product of a parent
who put her in front of the TV and then
left yeah yeah that's tragically same
thing with furries too the way I view it
it's Donald Trump should be furious with
Ronald Reagan because Reagan allowed the
insane asylums to be shut down and if he
hadn't then this woman would still be in
there did Reagan allow them to be shut
down or did he actually shut them down I
don't remember I remember they were shut
down though at some point barely alive
yeah yeah my parents worked at a mental
institution that's where they met oh no
kidding got married at a mental
institution in a chapel there yeah
that's so romantic false view yeah it
was interesting yeah my dad used to
there's one guy used to chew on the side
of the bed at a like just nervous rage
and you are an eternal will of
interesting stories again take a look at
this video this is this is a very old
video but we've talked about it before
this is like a trend where these people
do this thing and I can understand for
someone like her right she's doing a
performance she's playing It sped up she
recorded it slowly so she can get the
Motions right or whatever and there's a
bunch of these videos where I guess
she's famous for doing this thing where
she makes pixar-like faces
but this is resulting in real young
people doing this weird thing and
behaving in this way up until they're 30
and sitting on grand juries for a former
president that's a responsibility these
lunatics shouldn't have yo but this is
the next Generation it's not it's not
about this one person I'm gonna have a
president that does that yep that's
right
like we are going to
War well hello there friends let me tell
you about why I decided to Nuke China
you're gonna be like why are you why are
you doing that you're freaking me out
like well I'm just trying to bring some
levity situation I'm blowing up a
country here
I think that we're going to have a large
Port like we're watching the Decay
happen and I wonder if it has to do with
just very simply we consume media from
two different too many different sources
so humans used to be socially
conditioned by other humans but now that
we have the internet humans are socially
conditioned by Randomness on the
internet chaos algorithms machine
learning nonsense there are some kids
who will watch nothing but like My
Little Pony and then they get older and
they become like brownies or whatever
yeah and then there's people like I
think furries
identify with uh I can't speak for every
single Fury but they dress up like
cartoon animals like Looney Tunes you
know so I imagine when they were little
they were probably put in front of the
TV and their whole social interaction
lack thereof was just watching cartoon
animals anthropomorphized animals so now
that they're older they want to dress
and identify that way video games too
Final Fantasy 10 stuff like that you
play as like a cat man with a tail you
know and it was um uh or nine who who uh
was it Jeff younger I think he was
mentioning that uh that's a name right
Jeff younger yeah he was mentioning that
kids also play video games where they'll
play as a female character or girls who
plays a male character and then start to
identify that as them and things things
of that nature well I think I think a
lot of this actually goes to Pete
budage's defense and I don't like to
defend the dude but if you have an
entire generation of young people that
are coming up in this world view where
the Algos are messing with their brains
and they're just being raised by movies
and cartoons and stuff and then they're
they have to go make a living and
they're responsible for like vital
infrastructure like I yeah it's kind of
witch someone super chatted this they
said they found her Pinterest and she's
a witch I Googled it she's a witch
incredible yeah her Bonkers Pinterest
account which promotes witchcraft
promoting witchcraft does not make you a
witch practicing witchcraft does does
she practice thank you for clearing that
was a 20. that is that is that is
technically the truth thank you very
much literally the truth oh so is this
like a is this like a an ad for us to
read about how to become a witch we're
going to learn how to become a witch
today she's totally into witchcraft oh
yeah I want to learn one of my foreign
person in the Trump grand jury in
Georgia really putting the witch in
which wow yeah we're in a simulation I'm
sorry you can't I'm sorry we're in a
simulation can you go back up to the
first picture
there's you you you're not going to
convince me this is uh that all of this
is just like random chance that Trump is
like it's a Witch Hunt and then they
actually have a jury for a person who's
a witches to interview and that's who
they chose to interview too we we live
in it I've been thinking about paganism
a lot lately we talk about the Native
Americans and why the you know the
colonists the the Puritans didn't
consider them human they thought they
were Savage they were all paid they were
Pagan they didn't have the the monolith
of one God right of the monotheism thing
and so is paganism inherently evil does
paganism inherently breed chaos
destruction blood magic things like that
um
she's Slytherin she's at her house see
what she's doing with her third show see
what she's doing with her face I see
Christine blasey Ford and Peter struck
did that too yeah it's the cartoon
villain thing yeah it's like
when you watch a cartoon and the villain
goes like their head tilts down and they
look up I have no idea why that gesture
somehow symbolizes villainy but it does
apparently yeah what about tilting your
head forward and looking up is
villainous but we associate that those
those things so when she when these like
these people are doing this do they
think they're the bad guys are they
trying to be the baddies
with the Nazis she that proves it they
strike me as the bad guys but the I was
actually I just remembered where I was
stealing my point from it's uh one of my
Twitter buddies cernovich he he has made
this point like we don't have the the
mental capacity to fill all of these
vitally important jobs moving forward
like we don't we don't have people that
are going to school for it so I really
don't know what we're gonna do yo look
at this that's her
what happened what the heck there's a
video that's going viral where it's a
it's a it's a girl and it's multiple
photos and just a tick tock she posted
and the first one she's thin with long
brown hair and she's wearing like a
uniform with a tie then the next one
she's like smiling in a picture and then
then the last one is her fat with the
sides of her head shaved and a weird
haircut yeah and she's singing and then
and then a guy just goes what happened
is she so that's what she used to look
like she has like whatever Jacinda had
turns into Gollum slowly over time
did he hurt her is that what happened I
think college did bro she was not long
ago College yeah she looks like she aged
down like she looks like she got younger
I mean that could be the Witchcraft that
could be her at 10 or it could be her
today I have no idea I don't know she
looks like she's she looks she looks
like a witch lost some weight got a
little healthier like when I think of
which little that actually actually is
like looks like I mean Slytherin those
are Wizards witches yeah and they're the
Nazis yeah they're they're like the
white supremacists of The Wizarding
World that's right does witchcraft
entail blood magic is that inherent in
witchcraft uh I I do think wasn't there
a scene in the Harry Potter movie where
they sacrifice a chicken and drink its
blood there's something where they yeah
yep kidding I don't know if they
actually did no no no no no there is one
thing where they have to drink something
that's pretty gross I can't remember if
it was blood yeah there's a lot of
witches I don't think they drink blood
putting animals in a cauldron so there's
like blood involved in their potions
drinking blood is usually Satanism I
could be wrong though the dark Blackness
of Witchcraft like people are saying
meth in order to cast the spell I mean
I'm seeing meth now that you mention it
I've been around some meth addicts and
she's got the characteristics
you know Matt Walsh has convinced me to
be more demeanor to a lot of these
people so I'll look I'll accept that and
I'll say okay fine you know welcome to
the team Tim but uh
I I I I I I think drugs might be an
actual answer oh for sure her weird
Behavior I almost think that there's
some sort of um psychosis um the way
that she the mannerisms are kind of like
schizoid almost it's like it's like the
Joker remember in the The Dark Knight
when Harvey Harvey Dent kidnaps the the
schizophrenic guy who tried shooting you
know or whatever and then Batman shows
up and he's like it's a paranoid
schizophrenic from Arkham what are you
gonna learn from him Joker preys on
these people that's the thing you want a
grand jury to indict you want Grand
jurors who will say or do whatever you
tell them to do I bet they gave her the
ice cream and then they were like okay
we're gonna give you ice cream and now
you know she was really she got the
really important job too they gave her
the reason she gave her the poor person
can you imagine yeah that's the four
person like they really what the hell's
happening I mean like if you
like just a respectable attorney you'd
have to say to yourself like Ninja
Turtles sorry guys it was a Ninja
Turtles popsicle yeah I'm Legit jealous
truth here can we how do we order that
can you order this stuff because like
it'll melt I bet Amazon's got it you
could yeah but it'll dry freeze it over
good Lord yeah I'll try that'd be great
to get a whole bunch of Ninja Turtles
popsicles flavors depending on the the
headband color I hope they're like the
the creamy ones that are like cherry and
vanilla and then the Gumdrop eyeballs oh
yeah I was thinking about what you just
said about how Matt Walsh has encouraged
you to to be mean to at least Embrace
what's that to bad people to be mean to
bad people I think you can be mean
without being cruel that came up last
night we were talking that's what I'm
saying be academic about it it's
actually meaner to be academic about it
exactly which is undeniable it's not
emotional yeah no but like you can make
it emotional but you just say it in a in
a verbose way and it's more insulting to
do I learned that from Milo yeah he's
very good at it Milo's incredible yeah I
don't know what's what's happening now
Clint to answer your question why is
this happening I think maybe people are
checked out there's a lot of rich people
that I think are like just trying to
live the life on their boat and be like
I made it I don't want to deal with this
the world's always anyway right
well I think I honestly I think it's so
daunting many people are just saying to
themselves like I'm going to check out
for my own mental health like I can't
look at this all day I can't understand
all of the problems of the track that
we're on right now like world war three
is a distinct possibility and we don't
really talk about it in the serious way
that we ought to like it is it is
imminently possible that we have a
multi-front world war in the coming six
months like that's that could happen
does anybody think that was even a
possibility like yeah they they lied
about it being a possibility under Trump
but this is actually happening and they
have the American people so
psychologically manipulated that they
think that they're the good guys that
they're like yeah we're just gonna rock
with Ukraine we're gonna have inflation
that's running rampant we have all this
Mental Health crisis that we're dealing
with people like this and we're all
we're all on team good because we rock
with Ukraine and we've been told been
told that defending democracy is the
proper thing to do sure Ukraine isn't
actually a democracy it doesn't really
matter it's just narrative that's all it
is and no one pays attention no one
takes it seriously but I get it I
understand why people can't take it
seriously because if they did they'd be
horrified a lot of people are pointing
out it's called the Kubrick stare uh
yeah when you tilt your head down and
look up it's the Kubrick stare let's uh
let's jump to the story I got some I got
some exciting news for all of you guys
if you were uh not if you're if you're
worried about World War III uh fear not
there's something else that should have
you a bit more worried we have this in
the Daily Mail has bird flu jumped to
people
fresh pandemic fears as 12 more are
suspected of being infected in Cambodia
in same Province girl 11 died from virus
this week it's got a 60 mortality rate
by the way so if this really does start
to spread and it uh people don't it's a
flu though so here's the thing it's not
going to spread like covid would because
Cove was novel people have some partial
flu immunity already so it wouldn't be
as bad but it would be very very bad and
then I want to show you this tweet from
clay Travis he wrote last January 60 of
Democrats wanted to lock everyone who
didn't get the kobachat in their houses
over 40 of Democrats wanted those who
rejected the covet shot sent into
quarantine camps over 40 percent also
wanted anyone who criticized the kova
chat find and imprisoned over a quarter
wanted those who didn't get the covet
shot to have their kids seized now
they're trying to pretend none this ever
happened there must be consequences so
uh take a look at this polling from
Rasmussen
fine and imprisoned critics of vaccine
45 is almost 50 percent actually that's
amazing so uh as we move into avian flu
pandemic season potentially just uh keep
in mind what they have in store what's
the immunity like a Cambodia I mean do
they have vaccines do they have are they
a healthy no idea culture I I don't know
enough about Cambodia
no idea
yeah it would make sense why it'd be
higher fatality rate if there's well the
fatality rate is just in general there's
been instances where avian flu h5n1 has
infected people all over the world all
over the world yeah and and of the cases
they've tracked it's like between 40 and
60 so some Studies have said it's like
42 some have said 50 some odd and they
round up to like 60 and so I don't
believe it I don't believe it I'll uh
I'll link the data later they told me
too many times that people died with
covid and they said that it was from
covid when it was with covet and they
died of something else I don't believe
these numbers until I see absolute proof
80 different times from 80 different
sources and you're supposed to be scared
and then Panic that's that's what you're
supposed exactly that's what that's I
think that's the intention of these
flash in the pan like how many people
took that poll they said all those
Democrats wanted to lock people down was
like 4 000 people and they targeted
people in specific cities like I don't
believe it I don't believe it well let
me well I think reason actually does a
pretty good job on their on their
polling do they have a number and then I
mean mean I'm I'm looking at a graphic
from recipes and I'm looking at the
actual full service let me let me really
freak you out Ian that they'll try and
hit you with all this fear porn 24 7.
and then they'll tell you not to be
afraid of nuclear war they'll tell you
that you can actually have a preemptive
nuclear strike and Russia won't respond
they'll just lie through their teeth
about that stuff but then when it comes
to this stuff which I agree with you you
probably shouldn't be that afraid of
then they they overblow it it's
fascinating how they they really do
manipulate our psyche when it comes
that's because they want support for the
they want support for the war and then
there's more support for the lockdowns
Bingo yep yep so the question is not
whether Democrats want to lock you up I
think this poll wouldn't surprise me we
we know during the lockdowns all the
Democrat states were like lock it all
down like everyone in their house the
question is is the avian flu actually a
threat to us or is the media and
governments looking for something to
scare people to gain more it is scary at
the fact that 60 is a big number that's
more than half your family can die from
it and that scares people initially so I
think it's a way to more look for power
we don't know how much it's going gonna
spread we don't know what our immunity
they were doing gain of function
research on it in 2014 to make it
transitional transmissible among mammals
so so if we look at this objectively
okay there's like maybe every 100 years
we would get a pandemic right that's
that's what the statistic was so that
was the big joke is that oh 2020 we're
gonna have a pandemic because we had the
flu of 1918 and you know every 100 years
we're gonna go now we've had like we've
had covet and then they were like oh my
God now it's going to be the monkey pox
like oh my God now it's going to be the
avian flu and all these new pandemic
potentials keep popping up and then
there's there's gain of function on top
of it so so can you objectively sit
there and think is our government not
involved in this like is this just
happening organically a serious country
would have already imprisoned everyone
responsible for the gain of function
research that's my honest opinion and
until until you see something like that
happen until you see a presidential
candidate who's running on that and
Trump for the record you want him to
have a Redemption Arc In My Eyes he runs
on that he says I am going to get to the
bottom and I will imprison
the Republicans took the Senate uh Rand
Paul would have headed the health
committee that would have done that but
no we have
fetterman and no not anymore he's in the
hospital well he's there he was never
there anyways he was running the health
commitment look look you say like a
serious country would you think about it
I don't know if there's ever been a
serious country that would Target its
own Elites other than to sacrifice them
to save themselves
maybe so but I mean that's all the more
reason that I'm an anarchist yeah like
Trump wouldn't fire fauci I know and
apparently it was Jared Kushner telling
him not to do it or something but but
the the more down that pathway you go
the more irreparable the Damage Done and
I think that's what we're witnessing
both economically culturally just
civilizationally broadly we're just
we're allowing the degradation of
everything we care about our children
for God's sakes we're not even focused
on that like even to that extent people
still won't rise up to defend their kids
as they're being you know
psychologically manipulated into some
sort of death cult it's horrifying and
and like I don't have the answer I'm
just like I'm just like hey does anybody
else see this because if you do can we
come together for a second and say we're
not going to let our kids be destroyed
we can't do that any any civilization
that allows its kids to be destroyed
this is where Matt Walsh is dead on you
allow your generation of children to be
destroyed you have no future you have
none
this is horrifying you know I was
talking to uh rollerblader dudes who are
who work at work at the castle and uh
why is rollerblading why did it fall out
of popularity there were like 30 some
odd million rollerbladers aggressive
inline in the in the mid 90s it was way
more popular than skateboarding why did
it fall out because they did not
encourage young people to be involved
Escape uh skateboarders did and
skateboarders mocked rollerbladers and
rollerbladers didn't reproduce yeah they
did not have contests give up product to
kids and encourage them to be a part of
this community so then 10 years later
there's no one doing it the older guys
age out yeah the younger people mostly
don't I gotta come out of the closet
here Tim I was an aggressive inline
rollerblader at one point I mean it was
it was uh I think at its peak
rollerblade was more popular than
skateboarding's ever been yeah in 1999 I
dropped into the YMCA bowl with Tony
Hawk watching me it was a 12 foot Bowl
on my wow rollerblades it was and he
said I was the the youngest kid you ever
see doing no actually this was like 95
this was a long time ago the popularity
was like mid 90s yeah and uh they didn't
Inspire anybody so not to derail the
conversation the point is yeah no you're
right I guess 10 10 years from now a 10
year old kid who's watching Disney Plus
in the pride family they'll vote in 10
years and they're going to vote 100 for
critical race Theory bingo Bingo that's
all such such dangerous stuff it's stuff
I I left Massachusetts and went to
Florida to get my children away from it
and it's not something like you know
when people would ask why are you moving
to Florida you know from Massachusetts
I'm like oh I like the sun you know but
in reality it's you're all creepy
cultists stay away from my children you
freak yeah I had to save one of my
children from them and that's that's why
I that's why I moved can you go into
detail on that yeah please I'll go into
detail on that so um a few a few things
were happening I can go into detail on
this whole thing
uh 2020 happens and the lockdowns happen
and um I have a daughter who is um and
this this whole story is going to be
about that daughter okay she's
incredible she's 14 now but this was
happening started when she was 10. so
2020 happens lockdowns happen and my
daughter has this Condition it's one in
a million it's called chronic recurrent
multifocal osteomyelitis right and uh so
she has to go to Boston hospitals be
treated for that right and so they're
trying at this point
um you know fast forward like two years
one year ago whenever they were trying
to get this vaccine into kids and
they're trying to get this into my kid
who has this rare one in a million
disease they call it an orphan disease
because nobody nobody studies it there's
I mean Saint Jude studies it and that's
about it
um so they're trying to get this this
vaccine in turn then they're saying okay
well in Boston you can't you can't go
into a restaurant you can't go to a
Sports Coliseum unless you're vaccinated
if you're over six so I'm thinking okay
well I can't bring my daughter to get
her treatments and then take her out for
lunch because she's not vaccinated
because I didn't put this experimental
drug or whatever into my my young child
so that's a that's one portion of why
why I had to get out of there but other
than that I had a someone adult in her
life wrote I'm not going to go too
specific so an adult in her life wrote
me an email referring to my daughter as
a they them my daughter is a tomboy or
she was at the time up in up in
Massachusetts she was tomboy and so they
wrote they need this email referring to
her as a they them and I read the email
twice because I'm thinking is are they
referring to a group of people I
couldn't understand why my child was
being referred to as they them and then
it hit me what was going on and I I
asked like
did my daughter tell you to call her
that they go no I I didn't want to
assume I didn't want to assume they
didn't want to assume that she was a
girl because she was a tomboy and then
on top of that because she's a tomboy
she had people around her trying to tell
her she was gay so she came out to me as
a lesbian at nine and I was like do you
like girls and she goes no and I'm like
then you're not a lesbian like you need
to like girls she goes oh so so they're
telling her what she is so those are the
three the three reasons I'm like okay
you know what like my whole family my
whole life I spent my entire life in the
same town and I was raising my children
in the same town it was the town I grew
up in I loved it there but I had to get
as far away as I could so I took my
family and I I moved and went to Florida
and three months into living in Florida
my daughter is wearing pink and she has
a boyfriend and she's a totally
well-adjusted child and I she goes and
she gets her nails done with me and you
know she's very girly and she had told
me she goes I felt I felt trapped and I
feel like I can be myself now that we're
in Florida she's like I felt like I had
to be somebody that I wasn't when I was
in you know she would have naturally
outgrown this tomboy thing but it was
instead being enforced on her like
tomboy was a gender and that that was
who she was gonna have to be and so it
was really difficult to make that
decision I left everything I knew
everyone I knew I didn't have a job now
I do but I just I just left because that
was that was the most important thing in
my world was my children and saving them
and I saw them I saw people Predators
coming for my children
and I had to get out of there and so
that's what we did we left great job Mom
are you homeschooling at the moment I
have my children in actually a great
school that I very well vetted my
children are in excellent schools and
one of them is gifted I found out gifted
130 IQ and I another one got her letter
saying we'd like to test this one for
gifted too so I have these gifted
children and up in Massachusetts where I
was they didn't they didn't have
opportunities like that and I I would
never would have I knew they were
brilliant like just because I'm their
mom and obviously I'm a little partial
but
I I I think we need to acknowledge that
the phrase gifted is very problematic
because it implies that children orbit
slower are somehow not being given
opportunity so so it was a trickle down
it was CRT it was um that the things
that were happening in that District in
that in those schools up in
Massachusetts it all was uh everybody
had to be the lowest common denominator
so they so I had a smart child and my
one that's being gifted tested now
um she would be tutoring other kids
instead of having advanced work so you
see how they would kind of have her
helping which she loved to do you know
she'd do it but I'm just like can you
give her extra work can you test her
like is there anything more that you can
do to encourage her to be smart instead
of making her do your job
I mean that's fair right but so that's
something like as a mother that that um
was super important to me and it's
something I know I I have people reach
out to me a lot on my Twitter page or
whatever and they're like
I can't believe that you did that like I
want to do that I just I don't know how
I'm like you just you don't have a plan
you just do it exactly you just gotta do
it um I didn't I didn't have a plan I'd
have anything and then Tim reached out
and hired me and that was just like it
changed my life because I did oh there
you go did you talk to the kids before
you moved to get their opinions on
everything yeah they they weren't
thrilled about it because we were
leaving their grandparents their great
grandparents the all their cousins all
their friends like I don't I don't know
anybody in Florida all they had ever
known everything they've known
everything I'd known I don't know
anybody in Florida it's it's so easy to
do all you got to do is get hired by Tim
Poole and then move to uh Florida yeah
problems are solved I hope you're
looking to hire a couple million people
that happened the other way I moved to
Florida and then I got hired by Tim I
was literally like thinking I was gonna
go back to waitressing like I I dropped
everything I was gonna drop down and
just be the do whatever I could to
support my children move to this place
where they were safe and do whatever I
could to support them so so that's
that's what I did I was ready to go be a
bartender again or be a waitress or
something sometimes that's what's
necessary though and I had a very
similar Arc even though I didn't have
kids to worry about yours your decision
was way harder but when the lockdowns
happened I I realized it was untenable
and I I was running a very successful
mortgage company I shut it down without
having any clue what I was going to do
next I moved 3 000 miles away to a place
I knew no one and I just like pour all
of my heart and passion into this
podcast that who knew if it was ever
going to take off or do anything and a
couple years later it's like one of the
more popular shows out there so I think
that like I just I want to add on to
your story just telling people like
don't feel like you're trapped just
because you can't see the next two or
three steps in front of you doesn't mean
that they won't appear once you have
taken that leap of faith why did you
shut down the mortgage company
uh well primarily because I didn't
understand or I it became
untenable to comp continue to deploy my
investors Capital into an economy that
had so much uh
funny money that was chasing after too
few goods I knew that we were entering a
bubble I knew that the burst would
eventually come my my loan portfolio
usually as two to three year loan terms
I expected there would be a deflationary
bus at some point which by the way if
you want to talk about I think it's
coming very soon now
um and we're seeing the housing markets
collapsed well yeah not quite but Market
values are down I'm seeing the news all
over the place buying a house is it
going to keep going down or do you know
that can you say that kind of stuff out
loud are you is there a financial advice
I gave up my Licensing in California so
maybe I'm allowed to speak freely I'll
just say this is not Financial advice
it's just my opinion yeah it's going to
keep going lower yeah but where's the
where's the floor well that's the hard
part because ultimately you don't ever
know when the fed's going to reverse
course and when the FED reverses course
and they drop from the eight percent
mortgage rates is what we're dealing
with right now
um it's predicated off of like the five
percent fed funds rate well if they if
they reverse course and they could kick
the can and the bubble could come
roaring back you never know BlackRock
just made a statement that it's going to
be a recession I don't know actually I
don't know if they just made this claim
but that it's something not our old
tricks aren't going to fix this one is
what they're eluding yeah I think we
talked about that a while ago let's jump
to this next story we'll have a good
time here we have this from the daily
wire Vanity Fair published fashion
feature on Sam Brinton showcased
allegedly stolen dress I love this story
there's uh this uh not this one where is
it non-binary former Biden official Sam
Britain has been uh released without
bail the story is that there's this
woman who started Google searching Sam
Brinton after she found uh that he was
stealing luggage from the from various
airports she says that she had had her
luggage stolen and sure enough he's
wearing her clothes incredible she is a
designer I mean the story is crazy take
a look at this uh she's uh Asia Thompson
Christina Pasha says cultural
appropriation is stunning and brave as
long as you are non-binary this is the
stolen dress this dude Sam Brenton I
don't think it's non-binary all the
style of Sam Brenton Vanity Fair yeah
all the style that he stole that's so
amazing that he decided to he stole
luggage and then wore the clothing in a
photo shoot
I had something like that
doing
look man when you have corrupt people in
government they hire more corrupt people
and the corruption expands yeah and
we're getting to the point where it's
gone from corruption to degeneracy yes
Bingo exactly you know there you go
I just I just don't know how do you what
happens when you put mentally meant
there's something mentally not right I
don't know if it's a personality
disorder or a mental I I think this dude
is a kleptomaniac yep I think that he's
not non-binary I think his thing is
like he stole luggage and then wore it
in a magazine yep that's that's the
audacity but it's like I I think he's a
kleptomaniac he gets off on the
rushed and then like and then then
showing it off like keeping it like a
souvenir exactly oh like showing off his
kill or something yes exactly yeah
he was in a magazine or a fashion show
or something with this stolen dress like
that's showing it off that's going to
the highest place
look at me and it's allegedly look some
lady came on Twitter and said these were
these are my clothes that got stolen
yeah who made dress she said customers
and we know that he has been stealing
people's clothes and wearing it so it
just fits the mo it really does that's a
that's a great job there uh bite
Administration hiring this guy it's
custom-made so you know
she's so ridiculous see I'm grateful for
stories like this because it brings me
back from the the brink of Despair I'm
like this is funny like you can't you
gotta enjoy the good times who's been
fired right yeah yeah he got fired he
got prosecuted too yeah yeah well that's
the story here from Fox News he was uh
released without bail he faces theft
charges in Nevada people are telling
this woman to press charges he's he's
he's flaunting he's wearing the evidence
people like this ought to be stopped I
mean this is the type of guy that's
going to keep doing it in my opinion can
we be mean to him yeah
that's crazy that's cruel you can be
mean without being cruel like saying
he's a thief uh has no place in business
what about degenerate that's cruel once
you start insulting like name calling
what about the dinner it's not an insist
dude steals people's clothes from the
airport this that's not degeneracy
I didn't say he was like a poo poo face
yeah exactly he's a degenerate he is he
is bringing degeneracy to our culture he
is degradating our culture and Society
he is breaking its laws and uh and and
what's wanting this and what's worse is
he does it under the guise of being
non-binary which is I guess trans
adjacent I I don't know it's body armor
so yes so exactly it's body armor so
he's protected in the same way that you
can't criticize a child like David
Hawkins creeps out against guns this
dude's stolen dresses or body can't
criticize somebody who's on the spec
like it's a shield that they have you
can't criticize them for doing things I
have a huge list of nasty things I could
I could Ori about this fellow I mean I
use words for a living I could shred
this
set this guy into Oblivion with my
thoughts and my words but I will not
because I don't think it ends the
culture where I think it inflames it so
that's fair but I I at some point these
people should be laughed into Oblivion
I'll go down the mount Wallace Line of
thing here I mean like really this these
people should be in no positions of
power and anyone that has this type of
degenerate Behavior should not even be
considered for any job ever again these
people are crazy stealing stuff yeah
he's a criminal criminal I believe he's
been laughing at people mercilessly and
that's how you get power over them and
then when they call you like a bigot you
say your words have no power here and
then they just don't know what to do
because their words are their weapons
they hiss they go yeah they don't know
what to do yeah then they get pushed
back by the force of will look this guy
and then they indict Trump you just
right this is the problem is that one
side is constantly being like well you
know let's tolerate another side saying
we will burn it all down and that means
there is a a negative flow politics only
flows to the left it's the way I've
always described it if a right-wing
individual stands next to a left-wing
individual everyone says that left wing
guy's a right wing guy or the left does
the right won't call the left wing or
right wing but the left will call the
left Winger right wing right
it all Flows In One Direction the left
will show up with crowbars baseball bats
and Molotov cocktails and the right will
say slow down there Democrats you think
that's because when we start politics we
start the and it becomes that is the
conservative Benchmark for reality is
our constitution now and and it flows
towards change which is the left I think
yeah because the conservative part the
conservatives are saying we're going to
hold our ground here and the
progressives are saying we're going to
drag you over here if your entire
mission is to just stay in one place
well then the person that's trying to
drag you if they take you even an inch
well then they're winning
you're not ever trying to take it back
the other direction the conservatives
are the Overton window shifted so much
you could be a card-carrying communist
who's Pro Ukraine and whatever but if
you say
I think that you shouldn't be able to
kill babies after 30 weeks you're that
you're right wing right like that that's
how it only goes in One Direction yeah
and I mean with with the the physical
conflict too the the the the people on
the right save Matt Walsh are like well
hold on there let's not be mean then the
left puts pictures of kids being thrown
wood chippers because someone filmed
them at the Lincoln Memorial yeah like
yo Jesse Smollett goes and fakes a hate
crime
the the feds show up for a garage Paul
rope at NASCAR and then conservatives
Libertarians Independents this faction
are just like well you know we don't
want to be mean though it's like you're
getting flogged over the head yeah over
and over and over again and the only
thing I'm saying is like maybe we should
be a little bit meaner to these people
and shame them for being bad well I
think what's what's fascinating about it
is like the left now I'll say it first
by the way yes and but the left hasn't
taken over the culture with sunshines
and rainbows like they've taken it over
by shaming into Oblivion anyone who
didn't buy their nonsense for the past
30 years and much longer I'm just basing
it off my own life so like yeah I think
that you know turnabout is fair play as
they say in the UK like you should be
able to deliver them a little bit of
their own medicine and I think that
they've demonstrated that's actually
what you kind of have to do even if it's
against like my better instincts and my
better morals like I still if I want to
not end up in a hell hole then I kind of
enforced into the Matt Walsh world view
of like I'm going to destroy your spirit
just as you've attempted to do struggle
sessions these are struggle sessions
that are happening I mean look at the
last time it happened Marxism 101 yeah
but my concern is that the goal of that
or Mouse sect is to destroy the what
would you say destroy your uh how Matt
Walsh said If You're Gonna destroy my
what is it morale or whatever yeah I
think that the goal of that is to
destroy everyone's morale so if you
strike back by trying to destroy their
morale you're just feeding the victory
for them no it's like it wants the
collapse of everything so that hell can
break loose here's how it works you work
for a company and one day the boss says
hey there's some controversy related to
wokeness then the other partner at the
business says well if we side with
conservatives
then the left will destroy our building
and and maybe kill some of our family
members if we side with the left the
conservatives will complain on the
internet let's start with the left on
this one that's the safe safe bet that
is pushing politics in One Direction
well that paired with ESG and you have
just uh linear March towards the left
the thing is I'm I can't stop people
from being cowards and I'm not going to
become a villain to scare them into
following me scare who what are you
talking about these corporations that
are like well the right doesn't do
anything they just complain I'm not
going to create like some I'm not going
to threaten their lives we should do
that we said we should be a bit mean to
bad people you're saying that these
cowards and corporations that are afraid
of the left are but they're not afraid
of the right so that's the problem is
that that's why they're siding with the
left
of the conversation was we should be a
bit meaner to bad people I did not say
anyone should go and throw molotovs or
anything like that I said we shouldn't
do that antifa is bad for doing that and
that actually erodes their support
however it is an uphill battle but we do
need to tell the likes of Disney they're
scumbags when they do the pride family
racist trash and we need to then when we
see these people at conventions be like
you are human garbage and then not
associate with them and have them be
like why is this guy mad at me because
you are promoting racism in our country
and I will not be nice to you because
you're a bad person but not being nice
is different than telling someone
they're human garbage do not go to
events and tell people that they're
garbage that's going to cause mass chaos
do not do that I think the point is that
they want there has to be consequences
of the actions right and that's two
sayings there has to be a consequence
like they say they don't want they don't
want to
um to provoke the left because they'll
blow your building up you know but in
this case you have to in that situation
when you see someone doing this you have
to give them a card you have to push
back if you don't push back they're
never going to see any any then what you
say to them when you see the Disney
executive is you say I believe you're
cowardice and callow Behavior warrants
Severance from my contracts and my
business I will make sure that everyone
I knows will avoid your products and
your bottom line will be eviscerated by
my PR campaign whatever it would cost
you
in marketing I will cost you 100 fold in
PR damage you said something like that I
think economic is the way to threat if
you're going to threaten corporations
it's economically because that's what
they're afraid of when you say the
left's gonna burn their building on
they're afraid of the economic loss it's
not that they don't care about the
building itself you generally you
misunderstand you're saying I need to
take a lesson from the Communists on
this okay Ian you you can't see out like
you need to understand the analog and
not the digital you hyper focus on one
specific thing and you misunderstand the
bigger picture and the bigger picture is
when you have a community meeting and
the guy shows up who's been dumping
feces in the river you don't go well
hold on don't be mean to him guys we
need to understand why he's polluting
our water supply you say you out out
gone you're not welcome here anymore
we're cutting you off and you know what
we're turning the power off to your
building because you're using that power
to dump feces in the river we need to
just say ostracize bad people they are
not part of what we are doing they are
destroying it a guy shows up and he's
flinging feces at your children and you
go well don't be mean to him no no you
could be me doing that's a death
sentence if someone is attempting to
kill your kids by poisoning them with
feces that's a death sentence so what
would you call it when they're trying to
kidnap kids and sterilize them
I I mean well that way tolerate we got
to be nice
if they're kidnapping children it's a
felony I don't know what to tell you
that whether they sterilize their kids
when so when they have adult performers
perform for children in Texas and the
cops say don't look at me I'm not gonna
do anything about it
and you're saying well don't be mean to
these people now Matt Walsh is right I
said Don't Be Cruel you should be mean
to those people what you should
embarrass and humiliate them but not
because how is that not cruel well I
mean sometimes the nicest thing you can
do for someone is to humiliate them
perhaps fine whatever my point is the
people who are committing clear crimes
and the cowardice and the police who
refuse to do anything those cops should
be ashamed that's why I've been very
much like fine whatever about the police
because these cops I watch in Texas
they're like well we know there are
adult performers in that building with
children and we're not doing anything
about it it's like what dude it's
already illegal I I love Ian's
perspective because it's clear that he's
like he's leaning in towards his better
nature I have attempted to do that my
entire life for the record Ian I am now
in Tim and Matt Walsh's Camp entirely I
think that you have to you you can't
just put your foot in the ground and
draw a line you actually have to go on
the offensive and I don't mean violently
or anything like that ever I mean you
have to be on the offensive in terms of
changing the culture letting them know
there is a line that you cannot cross
you have crossed it so now I have to
push you back and metaphorically pass
that line because you're too far you've
gone too far already and do what the
left does when they show up to your
coffee shop you say I'm sorry you can
leave they do it to cops all day every
year you know you can't come in here
we're not going to serve you and we're
like oh I never we wouldn't do it well
you know what maybe the parallel economy
is the way it's got to go because
they're weaponizing this against you
while you try and be tolerant and play
nice exactly so if they show up to your
gas station to your oil change shop or
whatever you know auto shop you say uh
what did you need you needed your brakes
not not for you no you can leave yeah
have a nice day and I think I think if
you do that it's it's sad but if you do
that and people start to realize the
trajectory on that we're on maybe then
they will realize look there is actually
a price to be paid for dividing this
country based on ideological lines and
if they don't want to go down that path
they also have a choice to make can we
leave the kids alone or not because if
they do I think you'll see a much you'll
see a return to the much more you know
Christian conservative type Mantra but
at this point they've gotten so deranged
that you're going to you're going to
force the what are you normally very
calm people into taking a much more the
geoli perspective and stance I I believe
in fighting fire with fire when it comes
to this I want to tell you a little bit
about some communists so in the
Communists over in Europe during the um
during the the second world war they
released a message to the American
Communist saying if any
um if any dissenter becomes particularly
annoying you need to label them a Nazi a
fascist or an anti-semite
then fast forward
1947 or wait no 47 37 47 I think yeah uh
Walt Disney has to go before the board
and he's goes before uh Congress and he
tells them about the Communist
infiltration of Hollywood and
um and like how this is really bad and
he goes in depth and the Communists are
like really mad at him and they're like
all right we're going to destroy you
from the inside out we're going to taint
your legacy we're gonna we're gonna
we're coming for you it's essentially
what they did and if you think about
today what Walt Disney's company looks
like it is infiltrated with Communists
and filth and disgusting stuff and if
you also think about tainting him they
went on to call him an anti-semi and
that kind of faded into history as truth
um but there's there's not there's
nothing really that you can find his
company actually made for propaganda
films against the Nazis
um so I believe in like this is their
their tactics is they gained Power by
calling everybody a fascist everybody a
Nazi everybody in anti-semi and
sometimes you got to use gotta use it
again 80 years for the conservatives to
figure out the game yeah that's that's
that's crazy that's the game that's the
way we're gonna we gotta go to super
chats so we're a little bit over if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show your friends and
become a member at timcast.com because
we are now doing the members only
portion live and that means for those of
you that just want to watch it at your
own Leisure whenever you want once the
live stream wraps it stays on the
website same as it always has but now
you can watch us as we actually are
talking we're going to be setting up a
Discord where you can chat learn about
who the guest is going to be for the
night and ask questions in advance and
even call into the show which should be
a lot of fun especially when people call
in and say awful things but you know
where uh we can do that when it's
members uncensored all right let's grab
your super chats I'm not your buddy guy
says 43 was the great warmonger 44 was
The Great Deceiver 45 was the great
revealer and 46 is the great stealer
such wonderful presidents
yeah yep
I'm not your buddy guy then says Ian I
get you're a hippie who pursues peace
kindness and politeness but as a
Canadian I can attest to those values
only securing your oppression okay I
agree I had a friend once that was
really pretty he was a dick he would be
mean to me and then eventually I was
like you know what I'm tired this guy
has a crappy childhood his dad's a dick
to him smacked him around his little
Matt or so I call him to his face and
I'm like dude your dad just because your
dad treats you like terribly your whole
life don't take it out on your friends
and he stopped after that I also had a
girl that kept hitting me and I was like
please stop hitting me and she would
smack me and I was like if you smack me
again I'm gonna smack you as hard as
you're smacking me and she hit me again
so I smacked her and she never hit me
again after that nice there are times
when you need to strike back yeah I just
don't think the culture war is the place
for because it's about emotions and and
love we're trying to provoke love and
respect among humans based
all right let's see Raymond Jason JR
says Tim I missed your 4 P.M political
black pills they're actionable this
cultural Decay has me not knowing where
to start we don't have generations to
wait for them to breed out their run uh
ruin of society agreed Generations but
the the the 10 a.m and the 1pms are
effectively the same or similar to the 4
PMs and then uh the 4 P.M now is just
one of like so I've started doing three
segments four six and six thirty so
space them out so it's easier to watch
and then 10 a.m is what's the big story
from the previous day and this morning
and then 1pm is what's happening today
and then IRL is basically you know we
just talk about what the big story of
the day is so we're hitting from every
angle angle tomorrow morning we are
going to be launching the new show well
tomorrow afternoon and in the morning
I'll be recording the first show which
is General conversation and this is
really cool because um
we got some famous musicians there are
some people who have been canceled for
speaking up and speaking out they many
of the guests we've reached out to that
are like big celebrities or you know
industry you know prominent individuals
they'll say something like we would love
to do an interview but a topical news
format commentary is not our thing so
this once a week one-on-one interview
show is probably going to be able to get
us much bigger guests to talk about a
lot of these issues in a free-flowing
format so uh you know should be uh
should be cool
all right where are we at
Nate Parrott says Tim Timmy Tim Tim
Super Saiyan's eyes turn green you
uncultured swine
that's true they're green yeah they're
green no I'm pretty sure probably true
it's like a it's like a green blue it's
not exactly blue but
I think the original reason he didn't
want to start coloring it because
originally it's a manga so it's drawn so
he didn't want to color that that's
green blue yeah it's like it's in the
middle of the road but yeah it's a blue
it's a teal right we're both right right
the yellow is reflecting off the hair
yeah but actually in the only in the
colored version because previously he
just wanted Akira Toyama I didn't want
to color in the hair so if you just
color the outline it's blonde right
right yeah
Alessio damante says to bocus soon to be
the immortal cat due to stem cells good
job Ian saving him he's very happy and I
tell him when you guys are your comments
so thank you and then he peed on the
floor earlier son of a
he treats every room as if there is a
litter box in it whether or not there's
a litter box in it so just be warned if
you have them in a room I think that's
that's leadership right there that's
some some major energy focus is a Chad
yeah long cat
all right what do we got
Prince jabriquez says Albertson's
grocery released a vaccine ad saying
vaccines will be close to home beside a
picture of a banana with a Band-Aid on
it the implication being that Johnson
and Johnson is being injected into the
Johnson his into the Johnson is that
what they're saying oh I get it that's a
dirty joke oh
Tom Wolf said Buddha judge said he
wasn't there for a photo op yet he
immediately puts on a child-sized Bob
the Builder costume to protect him from
a chemical spill
yeah and then took photos it's just
whatever man
okay
Oro says Mr bocus runs to a corner and
pees while a clip of the view is playing
coincidence right behind surge man that
was nuts that was hilarious he was like
smell I can't tell I think it doesn't
smell you're getting a whip
yeah you guys stopped him though right
yeah that's like one of those things
where you as you grab him he just keeps
shooting out the back of him and you're
like uh where do I point this and it's
like hitting the wall going and you know
perpendicular that's bogus
all right Clint Torres says the left is
trying to make Trump into the Mandarin
from Iron Man 3. I don't understand what
that means how
the Mandarin was an actor are you
referring to the actual terrorist or
what he hated America America
that was a good movie I liked it a lot
of people didn't like Iron Man 3 I liked
Iron Man 3. the new movies the new
Marvel movies are getting kind of weird
you know all over the place
Matthew Moore says the Democrats on
media are actually fake I've traveled
all around the U.S and both Republicans
and Democrats are all on the same page
rural or Urban the American people are
getting Mass manipulated yes that's the
problem I'll talk to people and they'll
be like I'm voting for Joe Biden because
Trump's a fascist and I'll be like what
has he done let's say I don't know and
I'll say what do you what do you think
about this policy I disagree with that
well that's Biden's policy well I don't
know I don't care Trump's bad and I'm
like huh it's just the craziest thing
man well what was that that bill that
they didn't re-up under Obama that
allowed them to propagandize the
American people 2012 Josie oh that was
the the uh ndaa of 2012 they got rid of
the Smith munt Act and they they
repealed and replaced it with the Smith
modern the Smith month modernization act
which uh allowed for propaganda to be
returned back to the United States and
that's the same uh ndaa where they made
it legal to imprison citizens
indefinitely and also made it illegal to
protest at events that Congress puts on
that could disrupt things that happen so
if you want to think about j6 and think
about the ndaa of 2012 there's a there's
a lot what a convenient Bill to have
what a convenience just 10 years before
all of that thing came to pass
interesting and I just wanted to add
real quick Obama also drone struck an
American citizen without trial and Obama
also um took out a doctor's Without
Borders Hospital
good guy Nobel Peace Prize winner thanks
Obama yeah thanks a lot so uh someone
some Wayback says Tim did you see that
scientists on their way to East
Palestine to test the water the area and
water all died in a plane crash uh
so I have this from music I pulled up on
my phone environment workers die in
plane crash on way to Ohio Sports
conspiracies I guess they were going to
an industrial plant explosion not the uh
the train crash oh interesting well
that's still twin engine Beechcraft be
20 airplane crashed blah blah I mean it
said they died things are just tragic
coincidences I
I don't think there's anything to that
one but it's it is sad yeah yeah bummer
man
Merle Grace is the one thing I can think
of Obama did was get rid of don't ask
don't tell
oh was that him I guess if you're
conservative you probably are very happy
about that huh
or wait is that bad don't ask don't tell
I'm like I don't I don't know if you're
saying it's a good thing or a bad thing
yeah because well now look at how many
gay generals we have
yeah the guy with the dog face thing Pub
play yeah our military Readiness is just
awesome wait till China sees how many
women we have
yeah
that'll show them
yeah we're so screwed like what like the
conservatives at some point have to
realize like we really can't win a World
War so like why would they even I know
this is what really concerns me okay you
have the the left who has been
completely psychologically manipulated
and believing that like not only will we
win but we must
go to the end of the Earth to you know
defeat Vladimir Putin but then on the
inverse of that you you have a pretty
good anti-war uh fervor amongst the
right when it comes to Russia but then
if you just mention you know China or
the CCP to them pasovic comes to mind uh
then they are ready for world war
against China and I just feel like I as
a anti-war person a non-interventionist
person I don't have a political tribe
that I can affiliate with which is why
I'm in LP National somebody took the uh
the joke I was making the other day
about saying Putin should nuke Ukraine
and they yeah people started taking it
and doing exactly what what the joke was
they would do oh my God
funny
all right let's see what we got going on
let's read some more Super chats here
all right
John Eggleston says Pete loves trains
but not the type of train most people
think
I get it
and it's a dirty joke just for the
record that was the joke I made earlier
but I didn't want to make it explicit
all right let's grab some more where are
we at
T-Rex Pet Shop says Biden passed the
infrastructure bill it's his
responsibility I may not have your
special food but I'm guessing you need a
cat litter treats toy scratchers or
mealworms for chickens we do need
mealworms chickens you want to write
down T-Rex Pet Shop yes and we will we
will Source our uh
from you guys they actually messaged me
I saw your message I'm sorry I didn't
get to before but uh all right let's do
that
yeah we're uh we're very big how many
how many people in the Super Chat have
we hired
I think is it just one
one super chatter I don't know Charles
yeah I think so oh right now he's hiring
more Charles the half Armenian
accountant that's right the very same
was all right we're we're basically just
like people who super chat a lot we're
like hey you need a job like Charles
here here's here's a trick right I'll
let you guys know what we do is once
they Super Chat enough it all goes into
an account and then we're like we can
pay them with their own money
it's not Checkers this is genius Trump
40 chest section yeah that's right Cage
The Mix says Tim you should give Phil a
morning show if he's up for it and call
it what remains in the morning or if it
remains in the morning something along
those lines idea credit to Noah Sanders
who said it in his chat last night
that's hilarious well that's that's the
one thing we're talking about we're
talking about doing a Morning Show with
Phil so uh we could that'd be great nice
the one thing we're definitely planning
on doing is something to counter The
View getting you know so like it's kind
of a bummer that if you are a woman who
wants to watch women talking about
issues you get a gaggle of morons who
have no idea what's going on so it's
like can we get women who are not dumb
to talk about issues there's only one I
can think of well we got a handful of uh
um you know politically Affiliated women
who you know live in the DC area
frequent the show or of course Josie if
slash when you're around and then the
idea is just like yeah we gotta make a
show that you know all these women who
are watching The View just like turn and
then watch sane women talk about real
life and fact check it too that's some
real cultural War action to actually put
on that's really I mean we need to get
women who are feminine women who love
their children women who still can work
and still can raise their kids like like
these are the power asses these are the
women that are going to change the world
and those are the women that that I want
to surround myself with
um I I love like my base I have so many
women who follow me I I adore them and
they're all just incredible incredible
women and I need more of that we need
more of that as a culture to move
forward I we need strong women and it's
not the view Adrian Curry says there is
no such thing
well we'll they'll be better than the
view I can tell you that at the very
least if you took the view but then put
real-time fact checking in it people
would be way better off oh I'd love that
Elon higher than that Elon needs to do
the video I may have gotten kicked out
of tower gang for not just destroying
women when I had the opportunity and I
I like you I'm sorry I'm sorry guys okay
Joseph says why are you here Tim
um I'm doing Tim cast iron it's a show
it's bigger questions what are you doing
on Earth
um well I'm I'm hosting teamcast IRL I'm
I'm here right now you're at I'm talking
to you culture is Downstream from
existentialism maybe that's a better way
to view it IDK I'm dumb
well okay I I never really figure out
why the existential question why I don't
think there's something why why am I
here well you asked what are you doing
on Earth and why am I here and
technically the the bigger the bigger
answer to both is the same thing I exist
to collect free energy and organize it
into complex systems in essence negative
entropy however
we could only exist by producing more
entropy than entropy in which case our
function is just that it's like a golden
ratio yin yang yeah we're the we're the
the inverse of entropy but weaker than
it as everything spirals slowly into the
heat of the universe but that's your
purpose why beautiful that's what life
does my goodness yeah it's actually
cycling back into the center so you'll
never truly die it just keeps being
rebirthed the universe that's that's the
function of Life awesome the function of
life is to organize free energy into
complex systems and that's what all life
does it's what matter in physics tends
towards it's actually it's negative
entropy well when I see that nuclear
mushroom cloud I'm going to think about
that and you guys made me feel up that's
why I War rally on Sunday
is evil because it's ripping apart
complex systems into chaos so it's order
versus guess well and the splitting of
the atom is a pretty good
um you know metaphor in its own right
Adrienne Curry says women in groups are
exhausting they all talk over one
another what we'll do is we'll bring a
conch shell and then when the show
starts we'll put the Conch down and then
the women have to hold it if they want
to talk is it actually a woman thing to
talk over each other is it just bad
interview skills uh that the view the
view talks in order to shut out other
opinions if you see they invite people
onto the show and they just keep talking
and they do this and they just keep
talking over you and they just keep
repeating themselves over and over and
so nobody can get a word and they just
talk louder and that's totally
overwhelming so you can't get your point
across yeah that's that's a um
anti-debate tactic it's lack of
intelligence yeah well it's actually
very level one thinking yeah uh where
you throw out a whole bunch of things
really really fast so that they can't
answer them debate and then what happens
is like we have people on the show and
it's typically when it comes to debate
it's frustrating because they'll be like
listen when it comes Joe Biden point one
point two point three point four point
five now let's move on to 0.6 no no no
no no no no no you can't even dress you
just said six things we gotta go one
point at a time and debunk debunk debunk
that one's true debunk can I just make a
note because when I was on last time I
uh I threw the gauntlet down against
Bosch to debate me in Tennessee well
vosh ignored my plea but you'd be
surprised you stepped up Destiny so yeah
I will be debating Destiny in Tennessee
uh oh cool it's Tennessee Nashville uh
yeah Nash it's like an hour outside of
Nashville so take human actiontour.com
if you guys want to check it out it'll
be uh Tennessee will be a spot Josie
will actually be hitting a spot in
Austin Ian will be hitting a spot I'll
be hitting uh California as well Dave
Smith Scott horned a bunch of people
take humanactiontour.com but Destiny's
actually like in a lot of ways kind of
based you know like he's like he
defended Kyle Rittenhouse himself
defense he's not he's got he's got I
would say arguably more authoritarian
political views right but I I don't feel
like he's a liar you know what I mean
yeah no I think he's sincere and I I
look forward to the challenge I mean
he's a professional debater and I'm not
and I think that I have truth and
Justice on my side so I intend to
destroy him to save the world Anthony
Acosta says Emily cores looks like the
penguin villain from the Gotham TV show
no she does I see that she she does look
like a witch like when I think of witch
I think of someone who looks like her
you know I still think of Jacinda Arden
and kind of that Gollum she's oh yeah I
kind of see man yeah that Meme she's
turning into Gollum yeah but so we saw
the before and after pictures of uh of
Emily cores and I mean I saw I I saw
what I saw women have to stop taking the
fat like the buccal fat or whatever they
call it out of their cheeks like it's
just it breaks my heart you have like
you're in your 20s like everything about
you is basically perfect and then they
just like do all sorts of like the lip
injections it's horrible every man that
I know thinks it looks terrible and
women continue to do it to themselves
I'm like who are you doing it for it's
by each other it's body yes man yeah it
is it's uh it's body dysmorphia they
look in the mirror they don't see what
they want to see it's tragic I am
pandysis says look at her Pinterest
she's a witch with spells and crystals
oh so she's got crystals in not all
witches are evil I mean she's pretty
nasty I just want to know how much blood
she uses in her magic
That's How we'll know yeah you start
Steven Johnson says only thing I've
heard being accomplished from the
Democrats infrastructure bill was a 10
million dollar sidewalk in a small New
Hampshire town
oh sounds about right and also they
renamed many post offices
they do that a lot we the people says we
need to ignore these clowns and just
raise chickens goats and be happy
you know we got to do goat City
yeah
Adrian Curry in the chat again saying
preach make plastic surgery
self-mutilation again uh true yeah
what's the uh member chat uh floreal
says but Madonna looks great
oh I like everybody laughs that is a
sleep paralysis demon I think it was
actually Cassandra McDonald that tweeted
that if I remember correct
she is dude she looks just like it yeah
it looks like I've woken up to that
woman a dozen times it's horrifying
every time no it's it's the the cheek
okay so I have I have these cheekbones
I've had them my whole life and this is
what women pay money for when I was a
child I'd be walking down the street
with my mom and I'd have women growing
adult women come to me and try to touch
my face and say oh my God I'd pay so
much money for you know my mom's like
whoa don't touch my kid and I'm like
whoa what's happening here but it's
women pay a lot of money to look
um like
to have the cheekbones so you have like
an a-line shape to their face and that's
what Madonna it looks youthful because
your face looks lifted when you have
cheekbones she doesn't look young she
doesn't really believe she looks good
because she she clap back went out to
all the people who are like oh my God
like what is the matter with you like I
like you haunt my dreams you come in my
room at night yeah and she clap back and
she's like actually I look really great
now that the swelling is done she looks
exactly the same I know everyone was
dragging her exactly the same so so sad
though like
because of my age my age my mom was the
biggest Madonna fan and she just raised
me like listening to the material girl
and stuff when I was a little kid and
it's heartbreaking to see her because my
mom is now still so beautiful in her 60s
and Madonna just looks like a sleep
paralysis demon it's devastating
I prefer not to how about we just read
some more Super chats Gabriel Martin
says any word on Stephen Crowder give us
the inside scoop I I do have some
information I didn't want to say
anything
um until you know I waited a little bit
but uh when Crowder left here after
coming on the show as he was driving
away a rift in the time space continuum
emerged in our driveway swallowing his
vehicle whole and uh he has fallen into
uh the the um the twisting nether
between universes and uh we're never
gonna see him again uh he should return
last week
[Laughter]
I got no idea what Crowder's up to man
I'm sure all right slavkai Nikki says is
it is it kind of funny how we all memory
hold monkey pox after there were stories
and confirmed cases that they were
transferred to children
that's the only thing Pete puttage had
solved
Matthew Hammond says can Tim start a
series and have Josie narrate historical
events like her spaces with Sheamus
Coughlin crudely animating it similar to
South Park it's not a bad idea that's
actually a really good idea animating
takes a long time though especially if
it's going to be something longer than a
couple minutes oh for sure yeah yeah my
space is well my spaces go a long time
because of the questions if anybody
doesn't know I host revolutionary uh
histories faces uh probably about once a
week Clint usually does them with me
um and I just tell the history our
spaces hours exactly so um yeah I just
tell the history like I actually
yesterday was the day uh Chris
Christopher Cedar was murdered and
that's what kind of started the um
the in history I'm talking about 1770
right now but that's what kicked off the
Boston Massacre you know so so I would
have loved to tell that story but I was
busy because you know I'm here I'm doing
other things but oh I got an idea what
if what if we got people to talk about
history but they got drunk beforehand oh
my God I think I've heard that is that
is a novel idea you know what's funny
about that show stoned not about it
Drunk History was real when they first
started it yeah and then when it became
a TV show they weren't really drunk
right oh that's terrible I didn't I mean
watch it I mean they probably were
drinking but for liability reasons it's
like that makes sense well I think
Duncan trussell's was real because that
dude's a Savage and he would just do it
anyways you look at the early ones and
they're like throwing up and they're
getting sick yeah look at the later ones
and they're like they've got a drink and
they're like let me tell you I want to
do one called blunt history where I get
stoned I think the names and up to seven
dope name dude and I would tell so much
wrong history
yeah I'm gonna talk to you guys about
George Washington you know so it's
George Washington was was the first
president and you know I remember I was
at the grocery store and I had I had a
dollar bill with George Washington on it
we should go to the grocery store I'm
gonna get some some pizzas before we
start and then he gets up and leaves
history
Nick Pagan says I make end cap trap
metal under the name the agarist the
agorest started last month and I'm
bigger than all the bands in my local
scene those stream pay stubs and wasted
make music rebellious again yes okay
angry is my dude let's go I think we
have a new song coming out soon we
filmed a music video last last weekend
it's got to be almost ready at this
point that was hot yeah I mean the
song's been done for over a year and
we've just never put it out and I don't
know why we're just constantly just
sitting on these things keep your fans
waiting bro yeah yeah it's all good oh I
won't put it out right now right now and
then we've got like three or four more
songs that are like in the pipeline but
uh the next one's coming out it's pretty
good uh Phil labonte's music video
obviously he's been hanging out with us
beautiful we we we we he did sing but
we're like we don't know if the vocals
work because it's an old song but we
like if I would be honored to to do a
song with Phil oh yeah Rockstar but it
will have to be written specifically for
us together not like you know
but uh it should be fun we got some
other some other collabs Logan grimnar
says Tim the evil look you were asking
about is a sign of a preemptive attack
low ring in the head protects the neck
and the and and eyes while eye contact
is a sign of a challenge it's what
humans involuntary do involuntarily do
before striking oh does that make sense
is that what it is yeah their eyes are
harder to hit yeah and we actually have
the instinct to sense that because we've
been programmed over eons to fear it Sam
bankman freed did that too there's a
wild photo of him looking super
villainous sketchy
hillbillary Clinton says I know I'm
helping fund it but please take it easy
on the Grays everyone that wants to be
here should be if that's you then pay it
forward with a super chat God Bless yeah
I'm I'm a gray beanie oh the gray
beanies what's with what's with the hate
guys is a gray beanie a new a new member
yeah I agree but he's a new member
that's like the best color we chose it
for a reason you know I thought we were
talking I thought we were going the same
Tripoli route talking about the race
we had the Trump wrong Emoji I think it
was like yesterday I don't know I think
it was like a dare dare so before gray
beanies so many gray beanies slain
hoping Jr's got a got a goal a bronze
beanie with jewels encrusted to it
that's he's OG
he said Norm he's got out says Tim
please hire me to care for your chickens
I promise I won't stash an egg a day in
my pocket so that when when they are
worth more than their weight in gold I
can sell them to starving vegans we
already have a chicken tender it's Kim
it's Kim yeah she is our chicken tender
the chicken tender yeah I get it I like
it yeah it used to be my brother so we
had crispy chicken tender
ah we're very funny
Noah Sanders says can I get a b day
shout out for my little bro Isaiah we
watch together when he gets off work
we'd love to see David Lucas on the show
or the new Friday show sounds good happy
birthday Isaiah yes I'm cute Isaiah
Sanders happy birthday Isaiah I'm really
excited for the for the Friday show for
one I'm not going to be doing the news
segments on Fridays because we're going
to be doing potentially two new shows so
the other thing is there's uh I don't
know I'm gonna avoid saying too much
because I want to interfere anyone's
business but a company they want they
want us they want to license a show from
us as well so it may actually be two
shows from Friday start filming at 9 30
and then end at like two or whatever but
then if we do license a show it would
appear some other network but that would
really help us fund the operations and
stuff so it's an excellent opportunity
but uh so a tremendous tremendous
opportunities I don't want to say too
much about that but I'm really excited
for the new Friday show the culture war
with Tim Poole we're calling it because
it will just be one-on-one conversations
sometimes more than one person but think
Joe Rogan Club random basically to
conversations and walls call them up
let's go
um yeah like Matt on this show is great
as it is sure but often people are like
oh you have this really great guest why
don't you talk to them about this
specific thing and it's like we're
talking about the news and those things
do come up but we're basically talking
news commentary and most people watch
because the feedback we get is people
saying like I want to hear about what's
going on in the world today right and
then with the weekly show it's what's
happening generally in the culture yeah
so the thing is we've we've got
confirmed some uh very prominent
musicians and they straight up said I
don't think I could do news commentary
sorry not interested and then we're like
how about a one-on-one interview I'm
like oh definitely of course let me know
when and now it's like oh okay wow this
is gonna be great and uh we got hit up
by Ali London who's trans Korean was and
I think that's a huge conversation which
I'm really excited for so this is
basically what happened Ali had hit us
up you know Cassandra was like what do
you think and I'm like I don't I don't
know like he's we have so many people
hit us up but they're not news
commentary people so what do we do it's
like let's just do a new show once a
week to start that's just general
conversation around all these ideas
free-flowing why not and I'm like oh
that's a good point we'll do that nice
all right everybody if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button button smash
smash the like button there I did it
better head over to timcast.com click
the join us button become a member there
because we're going to have a Live
members only show coming up in about 10
to 15 minutes and then once that wraps
it will just be pre-recorded and it'll
be on the website forever you can watch
the whole Library we are currently
building out the system currently the
chat Isn't So functional you can comment
but we're going to have a Discord so you
can chat call in and all that stuff so
again sign up at timcast.com it is a not
so family friendly uncensored segment we
swear a whole lot and we say crew to
nasty things and we're much meaner than
we are in this show it's a sad reality
sorry Ian but it's true and uh you can
follow the show at timcast IRL you can
follow me at timcast uh do you guys want
to shout out your stuff yeah uh yeah
real quick uh Clint Russell liberty
lockdown make sure you subscribe I
literally just got my YouTube back today
everybody go over to liberty lockdown
and hit subscribe let them know that
they uh they made the right decision
um also Tower gang make sure you follow
my boys over there and uh at Liberty
Lockport on Twitter really interesting
opportunity I've been offered I will be
the messenger in residence for LP
National for the next three months uh so
I will basically be ghost riding the
majority of the tweets for LP National
on Twitter make sure you follow that I'm
the first person to ever do it there's
malice and other people probably will
get involved in the future so make sure
you guys follow that so you can see what
happens
and you can follow me over at trhl
official at Twitter and uh on YouTube I
think I'm the same thing I don't really
do too much YouTube but that's kind of
the other thing that I have but I'm
mostly on Twitter you can find me there
it's a juggernaut on Twitter live and on
fire
uh I wanna just also mention Clint you'd
brought it up during the show the take
human actiontour.com through the mises
uh party uh who's running it exactly
yeah it's it's mises caucus and um I
mean the lineup is crazy and the events
I think there's like seven or eight
different events all of the people that
you've you know probably seen on this
show uh will be involved including
myself and Josie and Ian I'm gonna be
speaking in um where is this coming up
in Oakland on May 13th and you can get
your tickets yeah hell yeah from uh take
Human Action tour.com you can get your
tickets there me and you will be doing
uh Cali together sweet dude so get your
tickets come out and see us it's gonna
be a lot of fun I think mazdaire will be
with us too I see uh I don't know if
Scott Horton I think is going to be
there too we got to get this uh this
live setup for the members only so all
right let's move this along
and I am at surge.com uh attack me on
Twitter bring it let's go all right
everybody we will see you over at
timcast.com on the front page of the
website you will see the uncensored show
pop up in about 10 or so minutes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see
y'all there